bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition de 24 heures Sénat et on
commence par le rejet en commission ce
matin du projet de loi de finance
rectificative par le Sénat 20 membres de
la commission ont voté contre ce
collectif budgétaire tandis que 11 se
sont prononcés pour ce texte sera
débattu en séance demain soir ce budget
confirme un déficit à 4,1% du PIB en
2013 en baisse de 0,7 points par rapport
à 2012 c'est un recul moins important
que prévu autre temps fort de
l'actualité au Sénat aujourd'hui c'est
le feu vert du Parlement à la nomination
de Jean-Louis Nadal comme président de
la Haute autorité pour la transparence
de la vie publique proposée par François
Hollande la désignation de cet ancien au
magistrat était accepté par 33 on le
voit contre 11 par la commission des
lois de l'Assemblée nationale et par 17
voix contre 12 par la même instance au
Sénat le bureau du Sénat qui doit
d'ailleurs se prononcer le 8 janvier sur
la demande de levée de l'immunité
parlementaire de Serge Dassault dans le
cadre du enquête sur des achats présumés
de vote à Corbeil-Essonnes le président
du Sénat Jean-Pierre Bel a reçu hier
soir de la Garde des Sceaux Christiane
Taubira la demande de levée de
l'immunité du sénateur
UMP de l'Essonne et dans un instant on
va prendre la direction de la salle
Clémenceau où se déroule une restitution
des travaux de la concertation sur la
réforme du financement des universités
cette réflexion sur le financement de
l'université s'inscrit dans le contexte
d'un enseignement supérieur bouleversé
par la loi sur l'autonomie des
universités bonjour thème oui bonjour
Delphine alors bien c'est un
réalisé par la commission de la culture
du Sénat oui tout à fait donc cette
réforme sur l'autonomie des universités
de
elle a effectivement tout bouleversé
dans les établissements d'enseignement
supérieur cette loi lrrue bien elle
devait apporter plus de liberté plus de
responsabilité aux universités qui
n'étaient plus simplement pilotées par
l'État alors côté positif il y en a eu
et bien il y a eu d'abord plus
d'ouverture sur le monde professionnel
et sur le monde économique côté négatif
et bien il y a eu de nombreuses
universités dans le rouge et oui
beaucoup n'étaient pas prête à piloter
leur enveloppe budgétaire et puis il y a
aussi eu de grands oubliés ces grands
oubliés bien c'était la réussite en
premier cycle ou bien encore les
conditions de vie et les conditions
d'apprentissage des étudiants alors ces
deux points en revanche ils ont été
abordés par la réforme de 2013 la
réforme du printemps dernier de
Geneviève fiorazo l'actuel ministre dans
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche cette réforme qui devait
d'ailleurs être une grande réforme
devait mettre à bas la loi Pécresse et
bien finalement rien de tout ça Delphine
puisque cette réforme c'est juste
contenter de retoucher elle n'a surtout
pas touché en revanche ah au grand
principe de l'autonomie des universités
merci beaucoup Tam pour vos explications
alors sans plus tarder direction la
seule Clémenceau poursuivre les travaux
de la commission de la culture du Sénat
et on se retrouve à 19h nous sommes
réunis pour entendre le bilan des
travaux du comité de pilotage qui réunit
depuis avril 2013 des représentants du
ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche de la Conférence des
présidents d'université de la Conférence
des directeurs d'écoles françaises
d'ingénieurs sur le thème de la réforme
du modèle de financement des universités
cette table ronde s'inscrit dans le
prolongement du rapport d'information
commun entre la commission de la culture
et la commission des finances consacrée
au financement des universités ce
rapport a été présenté par nos collègues
Dominique Gillot et Philippe Adnot à mes
côtés il a été présenté des battues au
printemps dernier
c'est pourquoi nous avons invité nos
collègues des Finances à se joindre à
nous mais nous savons que la plupart
d'entre eux sont retenus par les travaux
sur le collectif budgétaire qui sera
examinée par le Sénat à compter de
demain
j'informe les présents que nos rangs
risquent de se clairement certains ayant
des obligations de délégation aux
Affaires européennes ou d'autres travaux
et certains ayant l'ultime train de la
journée en période de grève
il sera utile de déterminer parmi les
recommandations que nous avons formulées
celles qui seront effectivement prises
en compte dans le cadre du nouveau
système de répartition des moyens à
l'activité à la performance dit sympa
qui devrait entrer en vigueur le premier
janvier 2015 je rappelle que nous
portons une attention toute particulière
à l'équité de traitement entre
université aussi bien sur le plan
territorial que sur le plan
disciplinaire cela suppose des
rééquilibrage de dotation au profit des
universités de proximité des universités
nouvelles accueillant une forte
proportion d'étudiants boursiers par
rapport aux grandes universités aux
fortes capacité de recherche mais
également des rééquilibrages enfin vers
des sciences humaines et sociales
structurellement désavantagées par
rapport aux filières scientifique une
des questions centrales demeure la prise
en compte de la masse salariale par le
modèle sympa nous avions préconisé
l'intégration de 90% de la masse
salariale dans le système les 10 %
restants pouvant être rétablis dans le
cadre du contrat
répartis excusez moi dans le cadre du
contrat il sera intéressant de savoir
quelle position le comité de pilotage à
adopter je laisse sans plus tarder la
parole représentant du ministère pour
nous présenter les avancées des travaux
du comité de pilotage sur la réforme
sympa pourront ensuite intervenir les
représentants de la CPU et de la cdfi
pour nous préciser leur sentiment sur
les pistes de réforme actées ou
envisagées et leurs attentes respectives
et je donne sans tarder la parole à
Madame la Directrice générale pour
l'enseignement supérieur Madame Simone
bounafou
merci madame la Présidente merci à vous
tous mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
de votre invitation nous y sommes très
sensibles nous connaissons l'intérêt
vous l'avez rappelé madame président de
votre Haute assemblée pour le système
fin de financement de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche et le
travail que vous avez fait à plusieurs
reprises nous en avons échangé avec vous
avec vous deux en particulier messieurs
et mesdames les sénateurs à nous et
gilots plusieurs reprises sur vos
rapports nous nous abreuvons nous les
connaissons et nous avons souvent eu
l'occasion de débattre avec vous de ce
que nous faisions donc nous sommes
contents de ce rendez-vous beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus large qui va nous
permettre effectivement de faire le
point sur le travail que nous avons
entrepris il y a déjà huit mois
puisque
nous sommes aujourd'hui donc je dirais
quasiment à mi-chemin de notre de notre
travail c'est une bonne occasion que
vous nous donnez en fait de venir
présenter devant vous ce point d'étape
alors simplement je passerai la parole
après au sous-directeur de la location
des moyens de notre ministère donc
monsieur forest que certains connaissent
déjà bien
simplement dire que notre démarche elle
se veut effectivement concerter avec en
particulier les les conférences mais
aussi avec le cnesser que nous tenons
régulièrement informé de nos de nos
travaux madame Gillot participe à ce
cnesser
nous allons rencontrer les 22
organisations représentatives au
printemps 2014 pour faire un peu le
point aussi avec elle
dans un esprit de transparence c'est
l'esprit de la loi ESR et vous savez
qu'il est prévu qu'il y ait un livre
blanc sur le financement de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche d'après la loi aujourd'hui
nous communiquons aux cnesser des a déjà
l'année dernière les résultats
universités par université école par
école ce qui ne se faisait pas
auparavant enfin nous essayons d'être
pragmatique en même temps que prospectif
c'est à dire que nous considérons et
votre invitation j'espère permettra
d'avancer dans ce sens de ne pas nous
interdire des voies et des questions
après on sait très bien que toutes les
voies explorées ne sont pas forcément
ensuite poursuivi mais je crois qu'il
est très important de ne pas fermer les
voix a priori et la stratégie nationale
d'enseignement supérieur qui va être
initié là par la ministre dans quelques
jours le travail sur la stratégie
nationale l'enseignement supérieur sera
d'ailleurs l'occasion de faire le lien
avec ce chantier là puisque ça doit
faire partie de la stratégie nationale
d'enseignement supérieur dernier point
nous tenons et Frédéric forest il veille
particulièrement à être comparatif
c'est-à-dire à ne pas ignorer ce que
font d'autres pays en matière de
financement de l'enseignement supérieur
à le réfléchir à son pas forcément pour
son inspirer au sens strict mais en tout
cas pas travailler dans un cocon
français voilà je passe la parole à
Monsieur forest
dit bonjour mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et donc merci pour votre
invitation à rendre compte de nos
travaux ce que je vais m'efforcer de
faire en 10 à 15 minutes maximum
donc comme la rappeler la directrice
générale nous avons entamé le chantier
de refonte de la location des moyens
selon une méthode
de fonder sur la concertation notamment
avec les deux grandes conférences le
chantier lui-même a été lancé en avril
2013 par la ministre et on trouve dans
le préambule à la loi du 22 juillet
l'objectif d'équité discipliner et
territoriale comme vous l'avez souligné
et donc nous travaillons dans cette
perspective pour être en pleine
cohérence avec ces orientations a priori
comme la indiquait la directrice
générale nous avons une interrogation
qui porte sur un champ large puisqu'il
s'agit de réinterroger l'allocation des
moyens mais également les stratégies de
financement les articulations ou au
moins poser les questions d'articulation
entre les différents outils de
financement
l'objectif est bien d'arriver à
construire un système ou à adapter un
système qui soit cohérent avec les
priorités
stratégiques évidemment comme vous
l'avez rappelé réduire les écarts de
dotation entre les établissements mais
aussi favoriser la politique de sites
les regroupements et la coopération et
toujours dans dans cet objectif de mieux
valoriser aussi le cycle licence qui est
politiquement
un des objectifs extrêmement importants
et articuler avec le rééquilibrage des
dotations
c'est donc un chantier aujourd'hui
clairement fondé sur la concertation
concertation forte nous sommes déjà au
septième comité de pilotage enfin elle a
7e séance du comité de pilotage nous
avons repris évidemment les
préconisations nous sommes avons pris
connaissance des préconisations des
assises et du rapport le déo évidemment
de votre rapport extrêmement complet et
mis en place un comité de pilotage CPU
ses défis MESR pilotés par la dg6 mais
en lien avec aussi les autres grandes
directions qui sont concernées notamment
la recherche et l'innovation ou les
affaires financières ou les ressources
humaines c'est une réforme qui est menée
en mode projet c'est à dire que nous
avons un calendrier des étapes clés des
thématiques successives un comité de
pilotage et par ailleurs nous avons nous
nous fondons une partie de notre analyse
sur des rapports de l'inspection
générale qui a mené des analyses de
coûts pour éclairer les pondérations
sympas
donc c'est une réforme conduite en mode
projet c'est juste un exemple ça c'est
notre calendrier vu de loin il n'a pas
l'occasion à être lisible là directement
mais c'était pour vous pour vous montrer
où est-ce qu'on en était dans le dans la
ligne du temps donc vous voyez on en est
là au septième la septième séance du
comité et pour un modèle opérationnel au
1er janvier 2015 non non c'était juste
pour vous dire où est-ce qu'on en était
sur les perspectives pour être ils l'ont
sur le
sur les perspectives là pour être plus
précis une fois rappelée ces grandes
orientations nous travaillons avec deux
mots d'ordre en quelque sorte c'est de
construire un modèle qui soit simple
ligne lisible et incitatif
aujourd'hui pour rappeler donc un
objectif aussi du modèle il s'agit bien
de guider la location des moyens donc
d'avoir un outil d'aide à la décision
aujourd'hui en tout cas le modèle n'est
pas conçu pour donner la dotation
directement versée c'est un outil de
comparaison et d'aide et d'aide à la
décision c'est pourquoi nous avons
proposé par exemple la suppression de ce
qu'on appelait l'excès
d'endinitialisation et nous proposons de
raisonner directement en termes d'écart
de dotation entre ce que calcule le
modèle de et ce qui est versé ce qui
sera plus simple et plus lisible
nous avons évidemment une question de
périmètre des établissements la question
est posée de savoir si nous conservons
un ou deux modèles est-ce qu'on
rassemble par exemple les écoles
d'ingénieurs et les université ce serait
possible les questions se posent il y a
évidemment l'intégration en amont de
certaines mutualisations évidemment la
réforme extrêmement importante des
écoles supérieures du professeur et de
l'éducation et nous avons d'ores et déjà
des hypothèses ou des qui permettent aux
nouveaux modèles de prendre en compte
des aspects qui soient mutualisés au
niveau du site donc c'est déjà le cas
alors que aujourd'hui c'est tout de même
plus compliqué
la question de l'articulation des
financements s'est posée la question de
comment prendre en compte la présence
des organismes de trouver un équilibre
entre le financement critérisé
c'est-à-dire le modèle et le financement
via le
contrats et qu'elle doit être
articulation avec les investissements
d'avenir par exemple aujourd'hui puisque
donc là on est en plein on est en plein
chantier et au jour aujourd'hui on a
plutôt une perspective on distingue les
outils de financement sans créer des
faits de substitution et donc chaque
outil de financement à ces objectifs et
essayer de créer une cohérence mais sans
forcément intégrer dans le modèle des
effets à ce titre là
sur les périmètres du modèle évidemment
on a un impératif qui est de prendre en
compte les avancées de la loi du 22
juillet de 22 juillet et notamment de
pouvoir s'adapter à la coordination
territoriale qui sera mise en oeuvre sur
les sites notamment ça peut prendre la
forme des communautés il faut absolument
qu'on ait un modèle et c'est possible
qu'il puisse prendre en compte ces
communautés voir leur allouer
directement des moyens si par exemple
elle porte l'espèce
la question de la prise en compte de la
masse salariale vous l'avez évoqué est
un sujet
délicat parce que la masse salariale
obéit à des déterminants particuliers
donc la question sera posée nous avons
un comité de pilotage qui est prévu
début 2014 sur ce thème il faudra faire
des simulations pour savoir quelles
peuvent être les impacts parce que
sur les nous avons aussi une des
questions sur les types d'emploi à
retenir globalement nous porterons et
nous le portons à chaque comité de
pilotage ce n'est pas forcément si
évident que ça d'avoir véritablement un
modèle simple et lisible et donc
d'arriver à bien séquencer et séparer
les effets tout en prenant en compte les
grands objectifs
très concrètement donc encore plus
précisément et
après je
m’arrêterai là plus précisément sur la
partie formation aujourd'hui
nous avons proposé le ministère à propos
de conserver des indicateurs d'activités
de performance ou de qualité aujourd'hui
pour l'activité sur la partie formation
a été discutée garder les étudiants
présents aux examens
on a par ailleurs avancé un principe
général qui est que on souhaite retenir
des étudiants dans le système qui soit
qui soit non financé par ailleurs et qui
induisent une charge de formation
en matière de performance et de qualité
nous avons proposé de mettre un poids
plus fort sur le nombre de diplômés
c'est aussi une leçon que nous tirons
des des modèles de financement à
l'international de conserver la
plus-value en licence qui est d'ores et
déjà enfin qui actuellement prise en
compte dans le modèle sympa mais de
rajouter la plus-value en master et de
prendre en compte la formation tout au
long de la vie et l'apprentissage par le
nombre d'apprentis sur le nombre
d'étudiants et la part des étudiants en
formation continue
est aussi en discussion un critère sur
le pourcentage de bacheliers
technologiques en IUT
sur la partie formation nous souhaitons
simplifier les enveloppes aujourd'hui
nous avons des enveloppes liées à la
compensation du TP égal TD
au plan licence nous nous souhaitons
réharmoniser et globaliser une enveloppe
formation la compensation de
l'exonération des droits des étudiants
boursiers est-elle traité à part donc
c'est une réforme qui est mise en œuvre
à partir de 2014 et qui sera traitée à
part pour arriver à financer réellement
et à l'Europe les exonérations de deux
droites qui sont accordés aux étudiants
boursiers donc ce sera hors modèle
nous souhaitons aussi harmoniser le
traitement des emplois et des crédits
il faut évidemment reconnaître vous avez
cité les sciences humaines il faut mieux
reconnaître les différences
disciplinaires et donc nous allons
fonder nous allons plus fonder nos
regroupements de disciplines et de
pondération sur une analyse des coûts
notamment en lien avec les travaux de
l'inspection générale de
l'administration d'éducation nationale
de la recherche
par ailleurs nous sommes posés la
question sur l'insertion professionnelle
il nous a parlé aussi aujourd'hui nous
avons un consensus avec les deux
conférences nous apparaît qu'il est
difficile même s'il serait souhaitable
de le prendre en compte il est difficile
méthodologiquement de le prendre en
compte et par ailleurs nous avons aussi
un retour de de parents gonnage
international qui montre la même
difficulté dans les autres pays donc
aujourd'hui nous proposons de ne pas le
prendre en compte à ce stade
globalement nous avons essayé de
schématiser de synthétiser ce que
pourrait être aujourd'hui les enveloppes
du modèle sur la partie formation et de
montrer
via des carrés qui sont qui seraient en
gros proportionnelle au montant ce que
pourrait être le nouveau modèle et donc
vous retrouvez l'activité avec les
étudiants présents aux examens les
diplômés la valeur ajoutée
l'apprentissage éventuellement les bacs
technologiques en ligne en IUT sur la
partie recherche de la même façon nous
avons des indicateurs d'activité et de
performance
en matière d'activité nous proposons de
retenir le nombre d'enseignants
chercheurs pondérés ce qui correspond
réellement à un affichage extrêmement
fort du financement de base de
l'activité de recherche via le via le
via le modèle et s'agissant de la
performance et de la qualité nous
proposons comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
de retenir à nouveau le nombre de
docteurs les soutenances dans l'année et
de retenir le nombre d'enseignants
chercheurs pondérés en fonction des
notes qui seraient données par le Haut
conseil si celui-ci remet des notes et
en alternative à la notation si elle ne
devait pas avoir lieu il pourrait être
envisagé de retenir trois critères le
nombre le nombre d'If le nombre et le
montant du précipit le nombre de projets
le montant du précipit
à NR et les réponses aux appels à
projets européens les réponses et les
dépôts pas les réponses qui ont réussi
enfin pas les on aurait ainsi une partie
liée à la qualité à la performance et
qui serait incitatif notamment pour
aller rechercher d'autres financements y
compris à l'international
sur la partie recherche nous avons
souhaité maintenir notre principe
d'avoir un système simple et le moins
controversé possible c'est pourquoi nous
avons évoqué nous avons échangé sur la
bibliométrie notamment avec
l'OL l'ost la DGI et les conférences et
nous proposons de ne pas le retenir à ce
à ce stade de la même façon de manière
internationale des questions il y a pas
il y a pas mal de de de débat sur sur la
prise en compte directe de la
bibliométrie donc nous avons aujourd'hui
nous proposons aujourd'hui de vraiment
avoir un financement de base des
établissements en matière de recherche
tout en tout en conservant des critères
de qualité de la même façon vous
retrouver un peu la même présentation de
ce que pourrait être
un premier l'esquisse parce que c'est
vraiment des pistes vous voyez on est en
plein milieu de du champ du chantier
mais les premiers indicateurs
nous souhaitons véritablement fonder
aussi notre réflexion sur les exemples
internationaux à ce titre je souhaite
souligner la participation du du
ministère au séminaire de de
l'Européenne université association nous
sommes allés avec Cécile tout au vent
qui est chef du département de
l'allocation des moyens au dernier
séminaire en novembre présentez le
modèle français et échanger avec nos
interlocuteurs sur leur modèle de
financement notamment à la performance
et nous allons profiter ce qui est une
grande chance pour nous d'un projet
européen qui est en qui est en cours qui
est le projet define qui consiste à
faire un partenage international des
modèles de financement et qui tombent
donc à pic pour notre chantier nous
invitons monsieur et c'est stermann le
13 février prochain a présenté les
résultats auprès de notre comité de
pilotage
pour conclure une espérant de ne pas
avoir été trop long les prochaines
étapes c'est évidemment préciser
finaliser les principaux principaux et
critères
engager une concertation avec les 22
organisations qui sont au cnesser donc
on aura deux à trois mois de rencontre
avec CC organisations pour discuter des
principes et voir si il faut les amender
nous engageons un travail de simulation
probablement assez intense au début 2014
pareil au printemps pour pour essayer
d'aboutir à un calibrage avant l'été
pour une mise en oeuvre fin 2014 et une
allocation des moyens de 2015 qui
serviront notamment évidemment comme
cette année CERFA sympa a servi pour
répartir les emplois une grande partie
des emplois au titre du rééquilibrage
des dotations entre les établissements
je vous remercie pour votre attention
je vous remercie
nous allons entendre les autres
participants donc au comité de pilotage
mais avant je voudrais ce n'est pas une
question de fond c'est juste une demande
d'explicitation qu'entendez-vous par
étudiant non financé par ailleurs et une
induisant pas de charge de formation
par exemple cette année nous avons été
amenés pour l'actualisation du modèle
sympa 2014 à neutraliser les étudiants
qui étaient par ailleurs inscrits en
institut catholique et qui demandait une
inscription qui aujourd'hui ont souvent
une inscription en université pour avoir
un diplôme national
il se trouve que ils sont inscrits à
l'université ils ont une note donc ils
sont comptés comme présent aux examens
il faut qu'ils aient une note pour avoir
un diplôme mais pour autant il
n'induisent aucune charge de formation
donc typiquement c'est un des ça peut
être un des sujets il y en a d'autres il
y a la formation continue par ailleurs
qui est financée par ailleurs donc
un établissement qui crée un diplôme
d'université
peut librement fixer les droits
d'inscription liées à ce diplôme donc
les étudiants ne sont pas pris en compte
dans le modèle sympa c'est on a essayé
de trouver de résumer de synthétiser en
un principe général plusieurs situations
c'est un principe qui a priori me paraît
cohérent et que le modèle s'il y a pas
de charge de formation a priori il n'y a
pas de raison comme pour les instituts
catholiques ou s'ils sont financés par
ailleurs comme pour la formation
continue voilà on pourrait trouver
éventuellement d'autres cas
je vais donner la parole à la SCPI nous
allons entendre son président Monsieur
Jean-Loup c'est l'Espagne
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
je vais faire une bref introduction puis
je laisserai la parole à Gérard
Blanchard qui vise président de la
Conférence des Présidents de
l'université donc
la digésie peut vous a présenté un très
beau modèle qui d'ailleurs ne cesse de
s'améliorer au fil et des de nos
réunions et on en apprend tous les jours
comme aujourd'hui nous en avons appris
un certain nombre et donc ça fera
l'occasion de de discussions parfois un
peu serré avec eux mais je voudrais
rester sur sur le fond le fond c'est que
ce modèle est extrêmement théorique mais
que s'il n'y a pas de moyens il ne peut
pas fonctionner et pour qu'il fonctionne
son moyen il faut du courage et quel que
soit les gouvernements il est
extrêmement difficile même avec beaucoup
de courage de retirer des moyens à des
universités pourtant valeureuse pour les
donner à d'autres universités je vais
vous donner deux exemples lors de
l'arrêt des moyens supplémentaires en
2011 le système s'est arrêté brutalement
et il n'a pas pu redémarrer parce que la
ministre de l'époque ne pouvait pas
prendre aux universités entre guillemets
surdotés pour donner aux universités
entre guillemets sous dotées on a vu un
autre exemple lorsqu'ils est agit de
régler le problème que la CPU avait
lancé qui était celui de la compensation
boursière c'est à dire le fait que le
gouvernement décide pour des mesures
sociales tout à fait louables que les
étudiants boursiers ne payent pas de
droit d'inscription sauf que ce sont les
universités qui les payent donc nous
avons posé le problème de la
compensation boursière et ce problème a
chopé immédiatement sur le fait que
certaines universités pour qu'elles
puissent toucher ce qu'il aurait été dû
il fallait que d'autres qui
touchaient de l'argent mais n'avait pas
le nombre de boursiers touche moins le
problème s'est arrêté immédiatement et
il a fallu trouver des sources de
financement ailleurs pour essayer de
régler le problème
et d'ailleurs dans la présentation les
choses ont été dites extrêmement
clairement puisqu'il ne s'agit pas d'un
modèle de répartition mais d'un modèle
d'aide à la décision ce qui acte
l'impossibilité d'avoir un modèle qui
fonctionne en l'absence de ouvrir les
guillemets grains à moudre mais je vais
laisser la parole à Gérard
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs donc je voulais
aborder quatre points principaux pour
pour apporter l'éclairage que de l'acpu
sur cette question de la réforme de la
question des moyens alors le premier
point évidemment concerné le principe de
convergence donc je n'ai pas répéter ce
que vient de dire notre notre président
très très difficile évidemment d'aller
vers de la convergence si il n'y a pas
une augmentation des moyens ça bien
fonctionné les deux premières années
depuis on a vu le modèle neutralisé et
complètement verrouillé par absence de
moyens supplémentaires on sait très bien
nous aussi en tout cas de la Conférence
des présidents d'université car
redéploiement de moyens entre université
c'est quelque chose qui sera extrêmement
compliqué qui serait extrêmement
compliqué à mettre en place et ça compte
nous conduirait en tout cas directement
faire une crise politique interne à la
CPU et probablement au-delà alors je
voudrais quand même saluer le fait que
aujourd'hui on a un exemple qui montre
que de la convergence est possible dès
lors des moyens arrivent en plus il
s'agit des 5000 emplois à nouveau donc
c'est 5000 emplois nouveaux avec 1000
emplois par an montre qu'effectivement
on peut faire un travail de convergence
et c'est la condition sinequanone même
si je le précise aussi la totalité de
ces moyens nouveaux sont pas mis sur la
convergence mais alimente également la
politique de site alors ce qui veut dire
aussi que avec la volonté d'aller sur de
la convergence dès lors qu'il y a
plusieurs mécanismes en parallèle et que
notamment une politique de sites ne
répond pas nécessairement à des besoins
de convergence on s'aperçoit que d'année
en année quand on fait le bilan la
convergence ne s'est pas aussi vite
qu'on le souhaiterait voir même dans
certains cas ne se fait pas du tout donc
voilà un petit peu pour le premier
principe général le deuxième principe
évidemment il concerne la masse
salariale c'est un point extrêmement
important puisque vous le savez c'est ça
représente 80% du budget des universités
et donc depuis le passage au RCE une des
revendications
constante et régulière récurrente de la
CPU concerne la nécessité de compenser
le gvt c'est pas une demande comme ça
par principe vous le savez ça représente
des sommes considérables pour les
établissements qui sont passés en ce
depuis la première année on a cumulé des
montants de dépenses supplémentaires non
compensées ou compensées seulement de
manière partielle qui font
qu'aujourd'hui évidemment ça crée des de
grandes difficultés dans les
établissements donc ça je pense que
c'est un point essentiel alors on se
réjouit effectivement du fait que le
ministère nous a annoncé que nous allons
commencer à rentrer dans un ensemble de
négociations qui pourraient aboutir à
mécanisme de compensation mais on sait
déjà qu'on sera de toute façon que sur
des compensations très partiel donc
j'insiste sur ce point c'est un des
éléments importants des difficultés
financières des universités
ça m'amène aussi toujours sur la
question d'un masse salariale avec dire
que l'acpu n'est pas du tout favorable à
l'idée d'intégrer la masse salariale
dans le modèle sympa c'est pas une
position dogmatique c'est que
techniquement on voit pas du tout
comment ça peut se faire et ensuite on
aimerait souligner le fait que les
déterminants de la dynamique de la masse
salariale ne sont pas du tout les
déterminants du modèle d'un côté on a
des déterminants qui re lèvent d'une
dynamique démographique en grande partie
et de l'autre côté on a des éléments qui
relèvent d'éléments d'activité ou de
performance de l'établissement donc
marié les deux dans un même système ça
nous paraît quand même relativement
compliqué en tout cas on n'a pas vu
comment aujourd'hui c'était possible et
notre position elle est négative
vis-à-vis cette idée d'intégration
le troisième point sur lequel je
souhaite donner la position d'acpu c'est
la structure même du modèle sympa donc
nous sommes d'accord avec l'idée que le
modèle doit être le prince un des
principaux leviers de mise en oeuvre de
la politique de l'État donc nous sommes
d'accord évidemment avec l'idée que tout
soit fait pour mettre en œuvre le
principe de réussite en licence donc ça
veut dire que dans la conception du
modèle dans la dans le dans le le
périmétrage des enveloppes évidemment ça
doit en tenir compte c'est la raison
pour laquelle la sécu est d'accord à ce
que l'enveloppe
réussite en licence le fameux PRL soit
évidemment intégré dans le modèle et
notamment dans l'enveloppe licence ça
nous paraît assez logique il y a
d'autres points qui nous paraissent
importants qui ont été annoncés dans la
politique de l'État notamment la volonté
de développer l'apprentissage et nous
avons entendu madame la ministre dire
qu'elle souhaitait voir multiplier par
deux le nombre d'apprentis et donc nous
souhaitons par la prise en compte de
l'apprentissage dans l'activité des
universités parent seulement le mettre
dans une enveloppe à part qui serait
liée à la performance il est vrai que
l'apprentissage est en partie financée
par ailleurs mais seulement en partie
parce que les coûts par l'apprentissage
sont très loin de couvrir la totalité du
coût d'un étudiant dans une université
voilà donc là on souhaite qu'il n'y ait
pas d'injonction contradictoire et que
le modèle soit l'expression
désorientations prioritaires de l'État
nous pensons également dans la réforme
du modèle que il faut aborder tous les
aspects évidemment les enveloppes les
critères et les coefficients sur les
critères mais nous sommes convaincus que
le premier élément de changement du
modèle c'est bien la définition des
enveloppes voilà donc je parlais tout à
l'heure de notre accord sur l'enveloppe
réussite en licence il y a une autre
enveloppe qui nous tient
particulièrement à coeur c'est
l'enveloppe des boursiers c'est à dire
la l'idée de la compensation boursière
et ça ça m'amène tout droit au quatrième
point que je voulais évoquer
devant vous la nécessité de la
compensation boursière réelle donc je
pense que tout le monde est d'accord sur
l'idée de constituer une enveloppe
indépendante qu'on sort en fait du
modèle sympa qui est à côté
mais pour alors aujourd'hui ça a été
évalué à 95 millions d'euros
c'est-à-dire en fait
les étudiants boursiers l'ensemble ça
représente une manque à gagner de 95
millions d'euros en ressources propres
des établissements alors il existe
aujourd'hui des mécanismes de
compensation qui ne sont que partielles
si on voulait faire une compensation
totale il faut apporter il faut
compléter à hauteur de 95 millions
d'euros nous pensons également et là
évidemment c'est pas une idée
nécessairement qui a été défendue
jusqu'à présent mais nous pensons que
cette enveloppe de 95 millions d'euros
les mécanismes de compensation ne
devraient pas être dans le modèle 150
mais dans le modèle 231 c'est-à-dire vie
étudiante l'idée c'est que les étudiants
même boursiers payent leurs droits
d'inscription université et que cette
enveloppe de 95 millions d'euros servent
à abonder leurs bourses pour les
rembourser de ses droits d'inscription
voilà les éléments principaux que dans
en tout cas dans un premier échange je
souhaitais avancer donc pour la CPU et
je vais laisser la parole à Hélène
paulia qui a un certain nombre d'autres
éléments à mettre en avant sur le
principe du décideur payeur
oui madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs juste quelques
points supplémentaires mais pour ne pas
alourdir la discussion davantage ou les
simplement aussi replacer dans un
contexte parce que une chose est le
système d'allocations des des moyens aux
universités une autre et le contexte
d'ensemble parce que ce qu'on oublie
parfois c'est que il y a des décisions
quand même tout à faites qui impacte
directement les universités en tant
qu'opérateur public en tant que ta
mission publique et que ces éléments-là
sont rarement voire jamais prises en
compte alors il y a des mesures qui sont
liées essentiellement à la fonction
publique je pourrais en faire toute une
liste mais je mentionnerai simplement
quelques interrogations que nous avons
pu avoir avec nous avons toujours sur
par exemple le financement de la
revalorisation des catégories C qui
impactent quand même aussi directement
évidemment
les universités j'en prendrais peut-être
un autre exemple qui est d'autant plus
significatif que alors là il aboutit à
un véritable paradoxe c'est la journée
transparence c'est qu'on en parle
beaucoup actuellement mais la journée de
carence a été
décidé par un précédent gouvernement ce
qui aboutit à nous retirer une somme
sans aucun rapport avec les coûts
constatés dans nos propres
établissements et cette somme a été
définitivement retirée de la base ce qui
fait que même alors que le jour de
carence va être supprimé nous ne
récupère pas la l'enveloppe de base qui
nous a été enlevé on pourrait allonger
la liste la loi TEPA avec un certain
nombre de millions de 29 millions et
demi qui ne que nous n'avons toujours
pas pu récupérer et on pourrait
continuer avec la loi sur le handicap là
je j'en profite pour remercier madame la
sénatrice Dominique Gillot pour son
implication dans cette dans ce dossier
parce que c'est vrai que c'est un
dossier difficile et lorsque les
universités vont entrer dans le
dispositif complètement c'est à dire les
pénalités pour non respect de la règle
des 6%, je pense que là il va y avoir un
véritable problème mais qui va très
largement dépasser à mon avis les seuls
universités où on va avoir des
conséquences politiques majeures donc
c'est vrai qu'il y a un ensemble
d'éléments surtout si ce dispositif
n'est pas accompagné s'il n'y a pas un
certain nombre de mesures qui peuvent
être préparés donc on a cet ensemble là
c'est à dire des mesures qui sont prises
par différents ministères qui impactent
directement et sur lesquels mais
finalement les universités doivent faire
avec leurs ressources propres quand
elles ont la chance d'en avoir et
j'ajouterai que je ne pense pas que ce
soit en nous formant rigoureusement par
la voix de l'ENA que nous serons bien
meilleure pour traiter ces questions là
en revanche je voudrais juste ajouter un
mot sur la méthode de l'analyse des
coûts
on a évoqué un éventuel enfin le
rééquilibrage entre les différentes
disciplines
on a évoqué le fait que l'on pourrait se
reporter à aux enquêtes qui sont
actuellement faites en particulier par
les NR la seule difficulté c'est que en
excès sur les coûts ça n'apportera
strictement rien de nouveau pour la
bonne et simple raison quand on ne donne
pas grand chose à une formation pour
qu'elle existe et belle continuera à
exister même s'il a pas beaucoup donc je
ne vois pas tellement à partir des coûts
comment on va pouvoir faire ou
construire une démarche qui pourrait
dire exactement combien il aurait fallu
pour que ça fonctionne peut-être un
petit peu mieux donc oui il y a sans
doute un rééquilibrage à faire entre
disciplines on a évoqué les SS de
manière générale impatience humaine et
sociale par rapport aux disciplines
scientifiques
oui mais là il va falloir vraiment enfin
tout est à construire puisque
effectivement encore une fois on se
fondant sur des coups constatés je ne
suis pas sûr qu'on est vraiment la
réponse en tout cas qu'on est un élément
de comparaison qui soit complètement
pertinent c'était les seuls éléments que
je voulais ajouter merci
viens je vous remercie nous allons
entendre la Conférence des directeurs
des écoles françaises d'ingénieurs
monsieur l'hermignon son président merci
Madame présidente
donc quelques quelques points rapides
d'abord je ne peux que nous la cinéphine
ne peut que qu'être d'accord avec la CPI
sur la difficulté qu'il y a réformé sans
moyens c'est toujours quelque chose d'un
peu compliqué et effectivement ça
demande des décisions qui peuvent être
difficiles puisqu'on voit bien que
derrière il ne peut y avoir que
réallocation de moyens entre
établissement et ce qui est jamais une
chose facile à faire passer et en tout
cas cette décision qui doit être une
mission politique qui doit être prise au
niveau de du gouvernement et pas quelque
chose qui doit être laissé en tout cas
aux conférences comme quelquefois on a
pu le voir dans le passé
deuxième chose attention quand même si
on réforme les modèles il y a un point
qui nous paraît important c'est
d'assurer quand même la continuité du
modèle il y a rien de plus difficile à
faire comprendre à des établissements
que le fait qu'il en 2013 ils étaient
sous dotés et qu'en 2014 ils deviennent
surdotés
et réciproquement donc attention aux
principes de continuité et ça c'est un
point de base sur lequel il faut
absolument absolument faire attention
alors maintenant si on rentre un peu
plus un peu plus dans les détails bon
quelques points particuliers se pose la
question effectivement de la fusion des
des enveloppes concernant les
universités et les écoles
là-dessus je pense que je pense que les
dessins animés que l'on fera nous
permettront d'y voir un peu plus clair
la série n'a pas d'opposition de
principe ni d'accord de principe il y a
quand même un point important qui est
que le nombre d'établissements qui sont
passés au RC au sein des écoles nées
loin d'être à 100% et donc c'est très
difficile de faire passer un modèle dès
lors que enfin de fusionner des
enveloppes dès lors que l'ensemble des
établissements ne sont pas passés au RC
donc ça c'est un point qu'il faudra sans
doute prendre en compte à ce niveau-là
concernant donc après le
plus en détail sur les
le principe de rééquilibrage par exemple
entre établissement du même communauté
là encore je pense que ça demandera un
petit peu de simulation en tout cas ce
qui nous paraît difficile d'imaginer dès
maintenant à rééquilibrage des
établissements au sein du même
communauté
dès lors que les communautés ont un peu
de difficultés à se mettre en route ça
risque de poser un certain nombre de
questions et de dire et ça risque de
d'augurer sans doute un centre de
stratégie tactiques dans la mise en
place des communautés si jamais ça c'est
annoncé dès maintenant qui risque de
poser un certain nombre de problèmes à
la mise en place de ces fameuses
communautés donc attention à ce principe
là aussi
concernant
les les critères eux-mêmes je pense que
alors en matière d'abord sur le problème
de la masse salariale j'aurais tendance
à dire et il y a ce défi il y a toujours
été assez favorable au fait de tout de
tout mettre dans le modèle sympa et pas
que la moitié des et qu'à la moitié des
critères la question effectivement se
pose derrière de savoir comment répartir
la masse salariale entre établissement
et comment la connaître exactement et
savoir d'où elle vient est-ce qu'elle
induit et je ne méconnons pas la
difficulté qu'il y a effectivement à
savoir ce qu'on doit répartir donc ça on
conçoit que c'est un peu compliqué on
peut se poser la question après
effectivement de savoir s'il faudrait
pas trouver un modèle dans lequel plutôt
que de mettre la masse salariale on
pourrait mettre déjà dans un premier
temps les emplois
les emplois bon c'est des choses en tout
cas qu'il faut regarder d'un peu plus
près mais il nous paraît difficile de
rester simplement sur un modèle qui ne
répartit que les moyens sont répartir
les emplois
à ce propos-là d'ailleurs il y a un
point qui quand même non négligeable
c'est un peu anecdotique mais qui qui
peut avoir un impact notamment dans les
discussions qui sont en cours en ce
moment concernant les mises en réserve
aujourd'hui une partie de la dotation
salariale des établissements passe par
la dotation de fonctionnement dans le
cadre du modèle sympa
pour la simple et bonne raison que il a
été donné aux établissements qui acquis
il manquait des emplois une compensation
pour un poids manquant avec un certain
montant financier
ces établissements ont utilisé cette
datation pour emploi manquant bien sûr
pour des salaires et quelques fois des
salaires de fonctionnaires
sauf que aujourd'hui dans la mise en
réserve si l'on ces sommes là sont
affectées d'un coefficient réserve
correspondant au fonctionnement et non
pas la mise et non pas à la masse
salariale dans l'occurrence pour nous la
dernière 06% dans un cas 5% dans l'autre
cas le 3% de votre cas donc c'est un
vrai sujet aujourd'hui qui a des impacts
non négligeables en matière en matière
financière
par ailleurs donc maintenant si on
reprend
moi je vais traiter le problème
puisqu'on parle de ma salariale sur le
problème du gvt nous il y a un principe
de base on comprend bien que un
opérateur de l'État un moment un autre
doit être négocié avec avec l'État ça
dotation entre et pour tous sans
préoccupation de ma salariale de gvt ou
quoi que ce soit d'accord à la seule
condition que l'établissement soit
maître de toutes les décisions qui lui
et que c'est celui qui gère sa son gvt
ça masse salariale ça veut dire quoi qui
n'est hors de question qui est des
promotions qui soient données à
l'établissement or de la décision de
l'établissement ça veut donc dire
automatiquement si on parle de
suppression des GPT conçu on parle de
suppression des promotions attribuées
par le CNU
et je pense que là ça va être la
révolution
donc je crois qu'il faut avoir ça en
tête c'est un exemple mais il y en a
d'autres donc attention faire en sorte
qu'effectivement les établissements
soient bien mettre de l'ensemble
de ce qui les amène finalement à
constater un juveté positif ou négatif
bien maintenant si on prend directement
les critères les critères du modèle du
modèle sympa je crois que
nous sommes d'accord sur le fait de ne
pas de ne pas considérer
les étudiants qui sont financés par
ailleurs pour nous c'est un effet
vertueux ça veut dire que si les
étudiants sont financés par ailleurs les
financements qui viennent d'ailleurs
doivent être totaux
en l'occurrence si un étudiant par
exemple est un apprenti l'établissement
de percevoir l'ensemble des frais
correspondant à l'apprentissage et c'est
fait doivent être répartis entre les
régions l'État et l'entreprise
financière aujourd'hui on sait bien que
ce n'est pas le cas donc ça veut dire
effectivement une modification radicale
du financement de l'apprentissage et je
pense que il est d'actualité puisque le
projet de loi sur la formation
professionnelle et est en discussion en
ce moment il faut effectivement imposer
le financement total de l'apprentissage
par pas par les entreprises et les
régions et les collectivités et l'État
ça va pas se faire tout seul et ça va
coûter un certain montant financier mais
sur le principe on est d'accord et ça
évitera quand on discute notamment avec
des industries avec des entreprises
qu'on nous disent mais toute façon vous
êtes déjà payé pour ces étudiants là
donc c'est normal que nous ne payons pas
en ce qui concerne les
le critère donc valeur ajoutée en
licence vous comprendrez bien qu'en tant
que président de la Conférence des
directeurs d'écoles françaises
d'ingénieurs nous considérions que nous
la valeur ajoutée compte dès lors qu'un
étui rentre après le bac et qui sort
quelque soit le niveau qu'elle sort et
pour nous la valeur ajoutée en licence
la valeur ajoutée en fait du SI d'un
étudiant qui rentre à bac + 1 au
démarrage et qui sera bac + quoi que ce
soit 3 5 8 c'est pas le problème nous
avons beaucoup d'établissements nous qui
ne délivre pas de licence mais qui
interrogue quand même des étudiants qui
rentrent au niveau du bac et donc pour
nous par définition nous participons
aussi la valeur ajoutée en Licence en
quelque sorte même si une déont pas la
licence donc ça pour nous c'est un point
fondamental aussi
en ce qui concerne les boursiers bien
sûr bien sûr il faut arriver neutralité
et nous sommes tout à fait d'accord
finalement à la proposition que faisait
la CPU à savoir effectivement
passer passer les boursiers les sortir
du programme 150 ça nous paraît quelque
chose d'assez logique
je crois que j'ai fait le tour des
quelques questions concernant concernant
la formation concernant maintenant la la
recherche on a un point qui est
important je crois qu'il va falloir
quand même qu'on considère ça au niveau
de la du financement des établissements
les établissements ont des coûts
importants concernant la recherche au
niveau de l'hébergement les structures
de recherche et je crois qu'il faut
qu'on trouve un moyen effectivement pour
arriver à prendre en compte
c'est un chercheur peut être réparation
établissement il peut être hébergé
ailleurs on voit bien que les coûts sont
pas les mêmes et si un chercheur est
hébergé dans une unité propre du CRS qui
n'est pas dans l'établissement et
cherche dans l'établissement on voit
bien que les coûts même si les
chercheurs peuvent être considérés de la
même façon ne sont pas les mêmes donc je
crois qu'il va falloir un moment qu'on
tienne qu'on prenne ça aussi en compte
sur le fait
sur le fait de prendre en compte de
remplacer la notation à res pour la
notation à la performance par par
d'autres critères je crois que on n'aura
pas le choix je pense qu'il était saint
il était 5 effectivement il y a pas
d'automaticité entre l'évaluation et la
dotation de l'établissement et un des
problèmes effectivement qu'on a eu avec
le comité avec la res anciennement et
bien tout le futur hcres c'était
effectivement cette liaison automatique
qui rendait le travail de l'évaluateur
un petit peu difficile et qui ne
laissait finalement à la tutelle et au
financeur que peu de marge de manoeuvre
puisqu'il n'avait pas décidé c'était
automatiquement les critères qui
décidaient de l'attribution financière
plus que de quoi d'autre je pense que ça
c'est un point effectivement qui peut
poser problème que on intègre dans ces
critères des critères supplémentaires
qui correspondent à la volonté politique
finalement du gouvernement à savoir le
fait que que la France récupère un peu
plus
des mois et de moyens de la part de
l'Europe par rapport à ce qu'elle met
comme cotisation me paraît relativement
sain maintenant il restera à discuter
effectivement effectivement des critères
en question de voir comment comment on
peut y arriver
dernier point concernant la recherche
attention aux ressources propres des
établissements nous serions tout à fait
opposés au fait que on tienne compte des
ressources propres pour calculer les
ressources les ressources données par
par le subventions ministérielle je
pense qu'il faut laisser les
établissements effectivement aller
chercher des ressources propres il faut
pas par symétrie dès qu'ils ont ils vont
chercher diminuer leurs ressources la
ressources qui viennent de ministères je
crois que c'est un principe qui me
paraît relativement sain mais encore une
fois ça va mieux en le disant
donc pareil en ce qui concerne bien sûr
le Pia et toutes les recettes qui
pourraient les ressources qui pourraient
venir des Investissements d'Avenir
encore une fois attention on risque de
budgétisation du paysa le paysa n'est
pas n'a pas de raison de remplacer des
dépenses budgétaires je crois qu'on est
bien d'accord là-dessus mais encore une
fois ça va sans doute mieux en le disant
dernière chose concernant les ressources
propres nous ne pourrions qu’être
d'accord sur le fait que on prenne et
c'est une recommandation vous aviez
faite au printemps en compte les coûts
complets des contrats de recherche je
crois qu'il faut qu'on encourage
l'ensemble des financeurs y compris
public
à regarder ce que sont les coûts
complets des contrats de recherche
alors aujourd'hui on a trouvé par des je
dirais des notamment pour les pour la NR
on a trouvé des moyens pour contourner
un pour essayer de contourner la règle
des 4% de frais de gestion en ajoutant
un préciput pourquoi pas je veux dire
mais encore une fois c'est simplement un
détournement du calcul de la prise en
compte du coût complet et je crois que
au niveau de l'État il y a maintenant je
pense au niveau des gouvernements je
parle du gouvernement je pense qu'il y a
effectivement une réflexion sur ce sujet
qui me demande aucun qu'on soit clair
qu'il ne demande aujourd'hui
aucune aucun déblocage financier
supplémentaire et j'ai simplement de
réglementation autorisé finalement que
les frais de gestion passent de 4% à 8
12 ou 15 ou prennent en compte
finalement les coûts complets ou les
coûts d'environnement c'est simplement
une décision et ça n'aura aucune
incidence financière
je pense que ça c'est quelque chose qui
peut se faire très vite donc ça je crois
que c'est important aujourd'hui le
principal bloqué je crois que la
réflexion commence à exister au niveau
au niveau du MESR et de Bercy je suis
pas sûr qu'elle existe au niveau des
collectivités et je pense que ceci
faudrait aussi bien sûr inclure les
collectivités et notamment les
financements CPR dans ce genre de
réflexion parce que c'est aussi un
financement non négligeable
établissements qui sont soumis
aujourd'hui à des coûts de gestion à des
fraggestions de 4% qui sont totalement
ridicules par rapport au coût réel
dernier point un point un point qui peut
poser aussi qui peut qui peut
quelquefois
être sujet à discussion c'est le
problème des frais de scolarité je crois
que clairement c'est le problème des
frais de scolarité est sur la table
aujourd'hui
on voit qu'un centre d'école publique
aujourd'hui l'école d'agents publics
sont bien parce qu'elles sont membres de
la Conférence sont aujourd'hui dans la
position d'augmenter leur frais de
scolarité
je ne sais pas jusqu'à quand le MESR
pourra continuer à maintenir ces
établissements compétitifs vis-à-vis des
autres ministères et vis-à-vis notamment
de l'étranger si on maintient les frais
de scolarité au niveau où ils sont
aujourd'hui bien sûr il faudra
l'envisager avec des mesures de
compensation je pense aujourd'hui aussi
que le financement d'enseignement
supérieur ne repose ne peut pas reposer
uniquement sur les frais de scolarité et
qu'il faudra sans doute envisager un
financement par les entreprises une
façon d'une autre mais mais je crois
qu'on ne pourra pas faire l'économie du
débat sur les frais de scolarité
je sais pas si Marc tu as quelques
points supplémentaires à rajouter
vous m'entendez donc juste pour dire que
nous nous croyons à la refonte de ce de
ce modèle nous y participons activement
et il est vrai que ce modèle de d'aide à
la décision à d'autant plus d'impact
qu'il y a du grain à moudre
supplémentaire et nous l'avons vérifié
au niveau de notre conférence sur la
poignée d'emploi que nous
sur laquelle nous avons travaillé cette
année à savoir une quarantaine d'emplois
neufs et là effectivement pour les
établissements on voit directement le
lien entre performances et résultats
sous forme de dotation en l'occurrence
d'emploi et on nous savons très bien
nous entendre dans ce cas-là pour que la
répartition soit le plus équitable
possible
pour la question du du redéploiement ou
de la convergence bien entendu c'est une
question délicate et mais il faut savoir
aujourd'hui que pour les établissements
qui ne voient pas en termes de résultats
une augmentation de performance tout
simplement parce qu'il y a un écrêtement
au niveau de la dotation parce que la
dotation réelle est loin de la dotation
théorique il peut y avoir un certain
découragement et effectivement il est
bon d'avoir un modèle d'aide à la
décision qui permettent aux
établissements de voir une possibilité
d'évoluer la question du périmètre
écoles université faut-il de périmètres
différents ou non et délicate aussi nous
y travaillons cela va dépendre des
critères bien entendu de répartition le
critère de l'insertion professionnelle
ne poserait aucun problème aux écoles
nous avons aujourd'hui une maîtrise
totale de notre insertion
professionnelle
bien entendu si nous travaillons dans
une enveloppe entre école ce critère ne
va pas être différenciant parce que elle
est quasiment la même pour toutes les
écoles ce qui ne serait pas forcément le
cas si c'est une enveloppe unique pour
l'ensemble des établissements nous avons
fait un travail avec le ua et notamment
Thomas sesteron qui a déjà été évoqué
sur les financements dans d'autres pays
et les modes de
répartition nous nous rendons compte que
dans des pays comme la Grande-Bretagne
la question du mécénat par exemple est
beaucoup plus développée qu'en France il
y a des pistes de dans notre pays
également mais là je rejoins ce que
vient de dire Christian si on veut il
faut encourager les établissements à
aller chercher d'autres financement et
pas les décourager donc il faut surtout
pas ponctionner dès lors qu'ils pourront
montrer qu'ils ont trouvé d'autres
financements ça me paraît absolument
essentiel
voilà ce que je souhaitais rajouter
merci beaucoup pour cette présentation
et ces regards croisés je vais demander
à nos rapporteurs s'ils ont des
questions des élucinations
Dominique Gilot pour la commission de la
culture de l'éducation et de la
communication alors moi je vous remercie
parce que c'est un travail considérable
que vous avez fait et on voit bien que
le dialogue
n'est pas terminée enfin les points qui
sont des points de convergence mais il y
a aussi des points divergents qui
méritent effectivement d'être approfondi
qui nous avait pas échappé ni dans le
dans le rapport que nous avons fait ni
dans les différents rapports budgétaires
et notamment les questions que qui sont
en cours de réflexion comme la prise en
charge de de la compensation de
l'inscription des étudiants boursiers
bon là on l'a vraiment
c'est ça me semble être d'actualité
d'autant que les nombres de boursiers
ayant augmenté la différence entre les
établissements ce qui accueille beaucoup
d'étudiants boursiers et ceux qui en
accueillent moins et vraiment
pénalisante pour ceux qui en accueillent
le plus et on a justement vu des
difficultés apparaître alors cependant
je pas rentrer dans le détail je crois
qu'on y reviendra plus souvent plus à
d'autres moments mais en revenant sur
les recommandations de notre rapport on
avait bien mis en évidence que la
convergence entre université par
l'affectation de la quasi-totalité des
5000 créations d'emplois sur la durée du
quinquennat
reconnu sous doté bon c'était c'était
une nécessité mais maintenant on
voudrait savoir si ces emplois ses
créations d'emplois seront suffisantes
pour assurer l'oreille équilibrage
complet
au profit des universités dites sous
dotés et j'ai cru entendre tout à
l'heure que quelqu'un qui imaginait
qu'il y avait eu des changements de de
classification
alors c'est vraisemblablement
lié à des
réécritures ou à des bons parce qu'il y
a eu des un travail de fait pour la
réécriture des budgets des choses comme
ça mais bon est-ce que c'est
véritablement accepté par les
universités est-ce qu'il faut qu'on ait
une nouvelle
configuration des établissements en
fonction de de l'actualité quoi de ce
qu'il aurait elle aurait été alloué
aujourd'hui
est-ce que ces postes ces créations de
postes permettront de couvrir
entièrement les déficits en emploi des
établissements sous dotés qui ressortent
du modèle théorique sachant que le
modèle il est en train d'évoluer et que
voilà c'est compliqué et l'attribution
actuelle d'une partie des nouveaux
emplois dans le cadre des contrats de
sites répond-elle à l'objectif de
convergence alors je sais que voilà et
Monsieur vous disiez que bon bah ça
posait ça posait quelques problèmes
parce que vous considérez pas que les
emplois sont des moyens vous voulez
qu'on faut faire la distinction entre
les moyens et on sait bien que dans le
dans le budget les les emplois sont
aussi des moyens alors en ce qui
concerne les pondérations et les
critères de répartition justement de ces
moyens est-ce que le nouveau le nouveau
modèle d'allocations tiendra
véritablement compte des éléments
suivants la proportion des élèves
boursiers dont la compensation intégrale
de l'exonération des frais d'inscription
est nécessaire et je crois que là tout
le monde est d'accord et que le travail
qui a été engagé par le ministère va
dans ce sens intense faut savoir comment
comment la réaliser et votre votre
hypothèse l'hypothèse de la CPU que vous
m'aviez déjà
fait passer au moment du de la de
l'analyse du budget de transférer
ce coup-là sur le compte de 131 bon ça
pose quand même le problème de la
neutralisation de l'augmentation des
bourses et de l'augmentation des
boursiers donc et là il y a vraiment une
décision politique à solliciter à
prendre en disant bon bah si
effectivement les étudiants boursiers
doivent assumer eux-mêmes leur droit
d'inscription parce que c'est une mesure
de transparence de lisibilité il faut
que la bourse soit augmentée à
proportion des frais d'inscription pour
que les choses soient neutres du point
de vue de l'étudiant et bien compris du
point de vue des familles
d'autre part il y a une autre un autre
élément qui qui doit rentrer en ligne de
compte c'est l'implantation d'un
établissement sur plusieurs sites ou
campus universitaire là et alors vous
l'avez évoqué sur relativement la
question des ESP mais bon c'est pas
c'est pas seulement pour pour celui-là
quand nous avions analysé le système
sympa on avait effectivement vu qu'il
s'était arrêté au bout de deux ans faute
de moyens supplémentaires ça ça nous
était bien apparus et mais on avait vu
aussi que ce système avec conduit dans
ces critères à fortement privilégié la
recherche au détriment de l'enseignement
alors faire réussir 500 étudiants de
plus en licence rapporte à l'université
6 ou 7 fois moins que
d'emploi et de crédit de fonctionnement
qu'une augmentation de 2,5% du taux
d'enseignants chercheurs produisant
alors j'ai bien entendu vous faisiez des
propositions justement dans le monsieur
quand dans dans
les pistes recherchées de réduire la
bibliographie pour éviter justement ce
enfin le poids de la bibliographie dans
le dans les dans les critères de calcul
mais est-ce que vous pouvez nous
apporter des précisions et nous dire si
vous avez des convergences
de ce sur ce point enfin il y a une
heure avait préconisé de redéployer des
moyens en formation en faveur des
formations tertiaires qui sont
historiquement moins dotés que les
formations secondaires qui sont celles
relatives aux sciences exactes et donc à
la recherche des développements et ça on
rejoint encore le débat que nous avions
eu dans le cadre de la loi sur
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
ça rejoint la question que madame la
Présidente a fait tout à l'heure à poser
tout à l'heure est-ce qu'on peut
envisager une pondération entre
formation dans le nouveau modèle voilà
je pense que vous l'avez dit mais je
pense que ça serait bien qu'on puisse le
redire et doit-on s'en tenir à des
coefficients de pondération entre
filières qui tiennent plus à l'histoire
où doit-on envisager des coefficients
plus normatifs qui sont qui seraient
cohérent avec les orientations de la
politique de recherche et de
développement économique qui est en
évolution et qui est nécessaire pour que
effectivement l'université soit un des
éléments moteurs du redressement
économique de la nation et d'une façon
générale est-ce qu'on peut aboutir à une
objectivation des coûts de formation par
filière au niveau de chaque université
est-ce qu'il existe maintenant des
logiciels de comptabilité analytique qui
permettent d'opérer des comparaisons
entre les coûts de chaque formation
c'est ça on a vraiment enfin moi j'avais
constaté dans mes travaux que on est
encore en
difficulté pour comparer les différents
les différents indicateurs d'une
université à l'autre faute d'outils qui
existent mais je pense que depuis le
travail de la mue a pu produire ses
effets et que vous-même vous y
travaillez beaucoup ensuite sur la prise
en charge des étudiants non financés ou
des étudiants financés par ailleurs il y
a eu dans la loi de finances là 2014 un
article qui restera le crédit d'impôt
pour apprentissage à des niveaux de
diplôme inférieurs aux diplômes
universitaires donc c'est en cohérence
avec l'objectif de développement de
l'apprentissage à l'université pour
justement favoriser mais par ailleurs je
sais qu'aujourd'hui il y a une
difficulté qui qui est en incohérence
c'est en incohérence pardon
non mais c'est un fourché et il y a une
réduction des pardon
mauvaise plaisanterie je disais c'est de
la stimulation par manque de moyens
il y a aussi le changement de la menace
de changement de proportion de
répartition de la taxe d'apprentissage
entre les les
organismes de formation et la région et
donc là il y a effectivement un
mouvement qui qui s'engage et qu'il
faudrait essayer d'équilibrer au mieux
pour ne pas priver les organismes de
formation de leur de leur de leur
subsidi voilà moi c'est ce que je peux
dire aujourd'hui mais je pense qu'on a
un grand un gros travail devant nous
monsieur le rapporteur de la commission
des finances philippe Adnot je vous
remercie madame la Présidente et tout
d'abord je voudrais vous remercier de
m'avoir invité à participer à cette
table ronde
féliciter le ministère de cette engagé
dans cette
mission difficile
parce que on a bien vu immédiatement
d'après les réactions que
et moi je pense je vous le dis monsieur
le Président de
la CPU la position qui consiste à dire
on ne peut envisager
de rééquilibrage que s'il n'y a des
moyens supplémentaires est une position
intenable ça veut dire que s'il n'y a
pas de moyens supplémentaire mieux vaut
garder les inégalités donc moi je pense
que c'est une position qui me paraît
intenable et que vous êtes à même je
vous connais suffisamment
d'imaginer peut-être des méthodes
différentes des partenariats des
méthodes qui vous conviendraient mieux
mais poser comme principe
on ne fera du rééquilibrage que si on a
des moyens supplémentaires c'est décidé
par exemple si pendant cinq ans il y a
pas de moyens supplémentaire parce que
il y a des contraintes budgétaires et
que la conjoncture s'y prête pas donc on
fait rien on en reste là
et donc je pense personnellement que
c'est une position
intenable et
mais pas plus tenant enfin intenable
dans l'université que dans des
collectivités ou dans tout ce qu'on a à
gérer tous où on est tous obligé quand
il nous manque des moyens de nous
adapter et de toujours essayer de
corriger des inégalités
alors
et donc en conséquence je pense que
l'introduction de la masse salariale est
importante à après ça on peut toujours
discuter de la part que ça prend et de
la de la méthode que ça doit prendre on
a entendu les différences
d'appréciations sur le sujet mais sinon
effectivement ce que vous dites en gros
c'est on ne fera de l'évolution
qualitative et du rattrapage que sur les
crédits supplémentaires c'est ce qui
s'est passé ces dernières années c'est à
dire qu'à ce moment-là il y a pas il y a
pas de réformes mais donc ça n'est pas
enfin de mon point de vue à moi ça me
paraît difficile
et la notion même de parce que le
système sympa je le sais puisque au
moment où ce texte a été voté il est né
dans les bureaux du Sénat par un
partenariat entre la commission des
finances et de l'enseignement
et suppose qu'il y ait des variations si
on récompense la qualité et il y a des
plus et des moins et donc par principe
tout le monde devra admettre que ça peut
varier en plus ou moins sinon sinon il y
a jamais de d'appréciation
de la qualité
autre remarque que je voudrais faire
parce que j'ai vu ça dans je voudrais
m'adresser à vous madame moi je
m'interroge toujours pourquoi diable la
politique qui consiste à décider qu'on
fait des communautés devraient
nécessiter des moyens supplémentaires ça
me fait penser aux problématiques de
l'intercommunalité en France alors on
décide que communalité c'est le must que
on va obliger tout le monde à passer un
intercommunité parce que nécessairement
si tout le monde est en intercommunité
ça coûtera moins cher et vous savez ce
qu'on a fait on a donné 3 milliards
d'euros de plus de dotation de
fonctionnement que les communes ce sont
des pressés de consommer en dépense de
fonctionnement donc
soit la politique des communautés est
une politique qui a un intérêt et génère
en soi des vertus et elle a pas besoin
de financement complémentaire soit elle
a besoin de financement complémentaire
et on ferait peut-être mieux de
l'affecter à un rééquilibrage de ceux
qui n'ont pas les moyens mais c'est
juste comme dirait un
moi j'allais dire un journaliste le
matin de bonheur c'est juste mon avis
donc ma collègue a déjà souligné la
contradiction sur la problématique de
l'apprentissage vous avez tous dit que
ça pouvait être une piste intéressante
mais on a vu que une décision de la loi
de finances vont finir par produire un
effet inverse j'ai une question à vous
poser madame j'ai pas bien compris
l'histoire du jour de carence ou plutôt
j'ai envie de vous poser une question
avez-vous été quand même bénéficiaire ou
pas parce que on vous a pris je suppose
une un prélèvement forfaitaire et
peut-être vous avez peut-être à celui
qui était constaté dans les
établissement oui c'est pas vrai ça n'a
pas produit les Français
les sommes que ça pouvait représenter
parce qu'on a tous les chiffres on a
exposition si nécessairement d'euros
avec la mise en place de
du système de la carence et donc
fatalement alors ou alors c'est que vous
avez été vraiment prélevé très très fort
donc vous n'avez pas eu de baisse quatre
fois et demi
fonction publique malheureusement on
nous a prélevé quatre fois plus que ce
que nous avons pu prélever mais quand il
s'est agi de remettre le jour de carence
on nous a pas remis l'argent voilà c'est
vrai que c'est une bizarrerie que vous
pouvez souligner je voulais juste savoir
ce qu'il en était concrètement parce que
quand même dans beaucoup d'endroits
ça avait provoqué on le sait bien les
jours de carence du lundi matin et du
vendredi après-midi
c'était une réalité quoi et c'est
dommage de de s'en être privé mais c'est
encore une fois juste mon avis madame la
Présidente
mais je m'interrogeais donc vous dites
et globalement sur les universités ça
c'est une masse de combien
d'accord
alors je voudrais revenir sur un autre
sujet qui a été évoqué et où il faut que
je pense qu'on fasse attention
je pense qu'il faut pas décourager les
bonnes volontés ni dans un sens ni dans
l'autre donc il faut pas mettre en place
des systèmes qui découragent les
universités ou les écoles d'ingénieurs
enfin
de chercher des financements et
améliorent la situation et puis ensuite
ou même par des étudiants parce que
c'est pas nécessairement évident d'avoir
de l'apprentissage et puis ensuite de
leur dire à vous avez trouvé des
financements donc
vous avez pas besoin des mêmes moyens ça
je pense que c'est le meilleur système
pour finalement faire en sorte que tout
le monde en reste
l'arme ok avec le minimum d'efforts et
donc moi je suis de ceux qui pensent
qu'il faut jamais décourager les bonnes
volontés et l'effort et que à chaque
fois que
une université fait des efforts et ben
il faut pas qu'elle en soit pénalisé
j'allais vous dire faites l'attention à
dans les deux sens l'histoire du coup
complet c'est une histoire intéressante
mais si vous êtes tellement vertueux que
vous arrivez à des coûts qui sont-elles
que tout un tas d'organismes seront
capables de faire le même boulot que
vous à des coûts beaucoup plus
compétitifs et bien vous n'aurez plus de
mission qui vous seront confiées et donc
si vous n'êtes pas à même comme une
entreprise
d'apprécier ce que c'est que le coût
marginal et la stratégie qui consiste à
dire si j'ai un volume d'activité plus
important ça va faire baisser mes
charges structure donc mon coût complet
donc je m'y retrouverai un moment donné
vous risquez tout simplement par
envie de vraiment tout faire payer ne
plus avoir de clients parce que vous
serez tellement cher que les gens iront
trouver le secteur privé qui rendra le
service dans les mêmes conditions et un
meilleur coût donc attention à ne pas
décourager pas plus dans un sens que
dans l'autre alors je voudrais terminer
par un sujet qui me tient à cœur que
vous avez évoqué vraiment et donc je
voulais vous interroger madame est-ce
que l'idée que nous avons énoncé qui
consiste à dire est-ce qu'on pourrait
rejoindre pour ce qui est de la
participation des étudiants la moyenne
européenne ce qui serait pas un truc
extraordinaire mais qui serait quand
même un petit effort de de d'abord
d'attention participer
d'attention de la part des étudiants de
participer à quelque chose d'important
enfin je veux dire c'est quand même
aujourd'hui ce qu'on demande à un
étudiant pour dire je m'engage dans
l'université je veux l'université de
qualité qui m'apporte des services mais
ça vaut rien
je pense que c'est nuisible
quand on veut avoir des étudiants
étrangers qui regardent et qui se dit oh
là là on me demande rien c'est que ça
doit être le truc
c'est pas nécessaire d'aller et je pense
que on n'a pas lieu de ne pas demander
un minimum d'effort on en est à des
sommes dérisoires n'importe quel jeune
qui se paye sa enfin tous ces petits
équipements
informatiques dans tous les sens ou qui
fument ou qui fait deux ou trois autres
choses ou qui s'inscrivaient même à un
club de sport n'importe quel étudiant va
payer plus pour s'inscrire à son club de
sport que pour dire je suis dans une
université qui si je lui donne un peu
d'argent va me le restituer sous forme
qualitative donc je voudrais connaître
votre sentiment pour savoir si la petite
question que nous avons soulevée dans le
dans la discussion à une chance
d'évoluer
madame Dominique Gillot
en entendant mon collègue il y a une
question que je voulais vous poser que
j'ai oublié c'est la question des
étudiants redoublants voire triplan qui
sont que les universités sont obligés
d'inscrire en priorité et qui conduit
quelquefois à ne pas avoir à cette place
pour accueillir des primos enfin des
premiers inscrits et qui entraîne
justement des après des procédés de de
tirage au sort de sélection qui font qui
voilà donc là il y a vraiment une
remontée difficile qui nécessite un
examen et qui va dans le sens de ce que
dit mon collègue c'est à dire que il
faut quand même que l'inscription à
l'université ça représente
un engagement réciproque de formation
bon alors je dis pas que des étudiants
très doublants ont retrétants triplants
sont pas on va leur place à l'université
loin de là il y a peut-être des
situations particulières qui méritent
d'être examinées mais peut-être sortir
de l'automaticité qui est gênante pour
l'accueil des premiers des premiers
cycles et qui va à l'encontre du plan de
réussite en premier cycle que l'on veut
mettre en place
féliciter Monsieur l'hermineau que j'ai
vu ce matin en venant dans le train que
Luc était quatrième sur la totalité des
écoles d'ingénieurs pour ce qui est du
classement des plus ouvertes à
l'international donc félicitations
alors
je devrais réagir de commenter ou de
donner les précisions sur les pistes que
nous rapporteurs ont évoqué on peut
peut-être laisser le ministère conclure
en conséquence la CPU les écoles
d'ingénieurs déjà si vous voulez réagir
et que le ministère rassemble ensuite je
vous en prie Monsieur cette semaine oui
je voulais continuer l'ajout de verbale
avec le sénateur Adnot joue de verval
qui
continue depuis plusieurs années non ce
n'est pas la CPU qui dit qu'il ne faut
pas faire de rééquilibrage non monsieur
le sénateur ce n'est pas nous qui
manquons de courage et ce n'est pas nous
qui disons que la seule condition aurait
équilibrage et de mettre du grain moudre
c'est la constatation nous avons
constaté que les gouvernements qui
soient de gauche comme de droite
ne pouvait pas rééquilibrer en prenant
aux uns pour donner aux autres cette
constatation nous amène à dire que quel
que soit le bord politique de ce
gouvernement ou de gouvernements il y a
un principe de réalité qui est que il
n'y arrive pas et que si on veut
arriver au but et moi je suis un
pragmatique comme mes collègues
ingénieurs la seule chose qui compte
c'est le résultat de la manip et donc si
on veut que ça marche nous sommes
obligés de constater que
il faut mettre un peu d'argent par la
totalité mais un peu d'argent pour
pouvoir arriver au rééquilibrage la
meilleure preuve comme la dit mon
collègue ce sont les postes
supplémentaires même si il est forcé de
constater que chacun de ces postes sert
dans plusieurs cases et donc est
réutiliser pour la convergence pour la
politique de sites pour la réussite en
licence pour les numériques pour
l'entreprenariat étudiant etc etc mais
je vais laisser aussi la parole à mes
deux collègues
redéploiement mais je pense qu'on a pu
que constater jusqu'à présent que ça n'a
pas été possible bien un prix politique
à payer qu'il s'agisse d'un gouvernement
ou qu'il s'agisse des conférences et
pour l'instant je pense qu'il y a pas
beaucoup de candidats pour payer ce prix
là le deuxième point que je voulais
souligner je vous ai entendu dire que
l'intégration de la masse salariale
serait une solution je ne vois pas
techniquement en quoi l'intégration de
la masalaï peut-être une solution très
concrètement en quoi l'intégration de la
masse salariale changera la question de
la redistribution
on aura une masse plus importante au
lieu de parler de 2 milliards on parlera
de 10 milliards ça change quoi sur le
fond concrètement voilà ça je pense que
c'est quand même une question importante
qu'il faut qu'il faut poser puis le
troisième point je suis d'accord avec
vous et notamment avec ce que disait
Christian tout à l'heure il faut pas
décourager les universités dans les
universités les laboratoires aller
chercher des financements à l'extérieur
et ça croyez-moi je pense que toutes les
universités toutes les écoles sont
parfaitement conscience de ce genre de
choses c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous sommes très vindicatif sur la
question de ce qu'on appelle le
précipite les frais de gestion parce que
plus on va chercher de moyens il y a
quand même des coûts de structure qu'on
a de plus en plus de difficultés
aujourd'hui assumer ça c'est le premier
point et je reviens sur la question
d'apprentissage parce que parce que je
crois qu'aujourd'hui il est pas naturel
dans une université de s'engager dans
l'apprentissage pourquoi c'est compliqué
ça nécessite une réorganisation complète
ça nécessite des modes de comment dire
de d'enseignement qui sont différents
c'est vraiment un des principaux
problèmes auxquels nous sommes
confrontés et surtout ça nécessite de
développer à une vraie relation avec
l'entreprise quand on dit un apprenti ça
veut dire qu'on est une entreprise au
bout tout ça c'est un travail énorme et
je trouve que ça ne soit pas justement
récompensé à être pris en compte dans le
modèle directement dans l'activité pas
seulement dans la performance je trouve
que c'est un peu dommage voilà et encore
une fois je le dis il y a effectivement
des financements annexes qui viennent
mais ça ne représente qu'une part
marginale du coup d'un apprenti ça faut
quand même pas l'oublier et je me
permettrais de faire un parallèle aussi
il viendrait pas l'idée que un
enseignant chercheur soit égal à zéro
dans le modèle parce qu'il va chercher
beaucoup de contrat de recherche or dès
lors que un étudiant s'en apprentissage
sur le métier égal à zéro ça reviendrait
un petit peu à ça donc je pense que sur
le fond il y a quand même un certain
nombre de réflexion à mener
je voudrais aussi je m'excuse répondre à
une autre marque qui n'était pas direct
de du sénateur Adnot les universités
savent très bien s'adapter à des baisses
de moyens on sait le faire on l'a fait
depuis des années des moyens de
fonctionnement ou des moyens en
masse salariale nous avons comme l'a dit
mon collègue
était capable d'absorber des
montants très importants de gévité donc
on est capable de s'adapter on est
capable de se réformer on est capable de
bien gérer ce que l'on dit c'est que
nous doutons de la capacité de quelques
gouvernements que ce soit de diminuer de
façon importante et non pas marginales
de manière inégalitaire c'est-à-dire en
prenant aux arbres donner aux autres
nous doutons de la capacité politique de
quelques gouvernements que ce soit y
arriver en tous les cas ce que nous nous
dit est-ce que dit Christian c'est que
reporter cette décision politique et ce
courage sur des conférences dans lequel
chaque membre est égal et dans lequel
nous n'avons pas le pouvoir
séculier de l'État ne permet pas de
répondre à la question
vas-y Dominique cette question du gvt de
son évaluation de son portage bon c'est
quand même quelque chose qui
en réflexion depuis plusieurs années et
on voit bien maintenant qu'il y a une
meilleure précision il y a une meilleure
connaissance du fonctionnement du gvt et
on a constaté que l'année dernière par
exemple j'ai été pesait un certain poids
il a été pris en charge à proport dans
une certaine proportion par le budget de
l'État cette année d'un seul coup le gvt
est plus important que l'année dernière
donc il faut continuer d'affiner cette
cette réflexion et moi je vous l'ai dit
déjà plusieurs reprises je pense qu'il
faut pas considérer le gvt comme un
comme une pastille comme quelque chose
c'est pas une matière comme ça
intrinsèque c'est quelque chose qui
évolue en fonction justement de la masse
salariale il me semble que au fur et à
mesure que vous allez maîtriser les
fonctions supports d'analyse de gestion
aussi des ressources humaines vous allez
être mieux à même de maîtriser ce gvt et
de réclamer à l'état ce qui revient
effectivement on a aussi parlé
quelquefois de transfert d'évaluation
des transferts de charge donc que l'État
apprenne à sa charge les charges qui
sont vraiment transférées comme vous
disiez tout à l'heure les décideurs
payeurs bon ça ça peut ça peut
s'entendre mais il y a aussi des
décisions notamment sur le gvt qui qui
sont de la responsabilité des
universités donc là il est important
qu'il y a une part qui une ligne qui
soit tracée que chacun et ça c'est par
l'expérience que vous allez y arriver et
on avait un échange tout à l'heure avec
avec la présidente et je vous l'ai dit
aussi à plusieurs reprises vous êtes
dans la situation des collectivités
territoriales à la première étape de la
décentralisation il y a des
apprentissages à faire il y a des des
structures administratives gestionnaires
et financière à mettre en oeuvre bon
certaines universités sont déjà bien
dotées
peut-être pas suffisamment et je pense
que au fil des années cette élévation du
niveau de compétence de la gestion des
universités permettra d'aborder les
questions là de modèles de répartition
des moyens d'une manière plus enfin je
vais pas dire décontractée ça serait ça
serait un peu trop familial et très bien
mais d'une manière beaucoup plus voilà
plus confortable avec des éléments de de
compréhension réciproque qui aujourd'hui
font défaut parce que bon chacun est sur
sa sur son sur son champ de
revendications et il va falloir quand
même qu'on avance parce que ce que
disait
philippe Adnot bon quand il y a pas de
moyens à redistribuer il faut faire
preuve de créativité d'inventivité parce
que sinon le modèle est complètement
bloqué
bien réagir je comprends
votre vécu difficile mais c'est vrai que
beaucoup de structurellement beaucoup de
choses que vous avez mis en scène nous
rappelle les premiers pas de la
décentralisation des régions les régions
ont été affectées par les problèmes de
gvt quand la direction de l'équipement a
transférer ses ressources humaines mais
quelques années après belles en ont fait
leur affaire et l'État n'a plus compensé
de même que sur ce point particulier
est-ce que vous êtes
dans les universités
employeur des personnes bénéficiant des
nouvelles conditions
permise par le gouvernement Sarkozy qui
était le cumul
emploi retraite parce que vous avez des
gens qui font monter le gvt puis qui
font valoir leurs droits à la retraite
et puis qui se font encore employés
étant en retraite évidemment ces gens-là
on les paye pas comme des débutants
est-ce que ce type de situation existe
dans les universités
extrêmement marginal puisque
la plupart de notre masse salariale et
d'évoluer aux enseignants chercheurs qui
partent à la retraite extrêmement tard
et c'est d'ailleurs une des deux raisons
de l'augmentation très importante très
importante du du gvt dans les
universités par rapport au collectivités
territoriales c'est le départ jusqu'à 68
voire 69 ans suivant les cas de beaucoup
de nos
personnels qui ont à cause des lois
fillons étaient amenés à déporter leur
départ à la retraite donc ça c'est un
effet local il y a un deuxième effet que
non pas à supporter les collectivités
territoriales ce sont comme l'a dit
Christian les promotions puisque
les
la moitié des promotions des enseignants
chercheurs n'est pas décidé par nous
donc nous la subissons et l'autre moitié
nous avons un quota qui a énormément
augmenté sur les trois dernières années
et qui n'a évidemment pas été compensé
par l'État donc deux types de dépenses
que n'ont pas supporté les collectivités
locales et un type de recettes que nous
n'avons pas nous ne pouvons pas lever
l'impôt malheureusement
tu as oublié je voulais simplement dire
que l'analyse serait sûrement très
intéressante à mener sur les structures
du gvt je suis sûr que pour une très
très grande partie nous ne maîtrisons
pas l'intégralité des décisions pour
lesquelles nous subissons du gvt par
exemple parce que nous n'avons pas la
maîtrise d'un certain nombre de
décisions et que dans un certain nombre
de cas on peut bien dire effectivement
qu'il y a un GPT une part gvt qui nous
incombe ça je pense qu'on est tout à
fait décidé à l'entendre et je pense
qu'on est même capable pour une grosse
partie de l'identifier simplement je
crois que enfin sans faire de la de la
politique fiction je pense que dans un
très très grand nombre de cas quand même
un certain nombre de décisions ne nous
income pas et sur les recrutements si
vous voulez on peut très bien essayer
d'orienter un certain nombre de
décisions c'est quand même très
difficile d'intervenir dans des jurys en
particulier quand on fait des
recrutements et que il y a tout un tas
de de
d'éléments qui affecte l'évolution de la
masse salariale qui ne relève absolument
pas des universités toute la
reconstitution de carrière et la prise
en compte des maîtres de conférence en
début de carrière par exemple depuis
2009 c'est bien quelque chose qui a été
décidé et bon voilà on l'a donné etc
mais c'est du gvt on c'est l'évolution
de la masse salariale
on va arrêter les comparaisons avec les
collectivités mais je peux vous dire
pour avoir présidé une région que les
salaires des ingénieurs de la fonction
publique territoriale ou le nombre de
promotions
obéissent à des lois sociales à des
cadrages qui échappent totalement au
pilotage des ressources humaines et qui
s'imposent au budget de la collectivité
mais voilà sur ce c'est pas facile mais
droit d'inscription
-là ne menait on va donner
la pignon juste pour répondre à quelques
questions et puis effectivement pour
juste donner notre point de vue là
dessus je crois qu'effectivement la
différence aujourd'hui est dans le fait
que peut-on pas lever l'impôt nous on
lève pas l'impôt mais on pourrait lever
autre chose donc là c'est une discussion
qu'au sur les autres on va reprendre
mais qui me paraît à mon avis enfin qui
va être incontournable on le sait tous
alors on sait pas quand ça va arriver
mais ça finir par arriver sur la table
un jour ou l'autre bon juste pour
répondre la question que vous aviez
posée concernant est-ce que la question
sur les 5000 emplois est-ce sera
suffisant je serai peut-être
général répondre mais il est clair que
de notre point de vue et je pense que la
cpuire la même chose non ça sera pas
suffisant on arrivera pas à avoir un Dr
sur DT égal à 1 pour tous les
établissements je veux dire une fois
qu'on aura distribué les 5000 emplois ça
faut être réaliste si on a réduit déjà
les écarts de 20% ce sera déjà beaucoup
on verra on verra
concernant la question sur la recherche
versus formation la question que vous
aviez posée à savoir effectivement
vaut-il mieux finalement former 500
étudiants de plus en Licence ou avoir
deux ou trois si on cherche à produire
de plus je crois que là c'est une vraie
question que doit se poser la société et
et finalement qu'on doit se poser entre
nous la stratégie nationale d'un silence
doit poser cette vraie question faut-il
plus de produisant ou plus d'étudiants
formés et à partir du moment où on se
donne on se donne un objectif je pense
qu'on peut mettre le système de
répartition en accord avec cet objectif
c'est que je pense qu'à un moment ou un
autre il faudra que ce système de
répartition qu'on va mettre en place et
les pondérations entre les différents
critères vont dépendre effectivement de
la décision que l'on prend au niveau
stratégique et je crois que une très
bonne chose dans la loi qui a été votée
c'est le fait qu'il y a une stratégie
nationale de l'enseignement supérieur
maintenant je crois qu'il faut
effectivement qu'on aborde ces espèces
stratégiques très vite
après juste des questions que vous aviez
posées sur lesquelles je veux juste
répondre rapidement formation tertiaire
versus secondaire le fait de savoir
comment on pondèrent et je crois que
c'est déjà en partie pondérée et puis et
puis que l'autre chose on sait bien même
nous je dirais dans les formations
d'ingénieurs aujourd'hui les formations
d'ingénieurs sont pondérées de la même
façon quel que soit la formation
d'ingénieur on sait très bien nous qu'un
ingénieur informaticien coûte moins cher
à produire qu'un ingénieur en génie des
procédés il y a pas photo il y a un
facteur 3 pourtant ils ont ils ont donc
je crois que ils ont le même coefficient
donc je crois que là il y a vraiment un
travail de fond à fournir mais qui va
être bon qui va demander à rentrer
au-delà de l'analyse de coût aujourd'hui
qui est un des critères et je suis
d'accord avec la CPU derrière ça il y a
effectivement tout le côté étude des
maquettes et je pense qu'il est
important derrière il faut que toutes
nos formations et effectivement
aujourd'hui un référentiel et des
maquettes je crois que le travail qui
est engagé au niveau du cadre national
des formations aujourd'hui devrait
pouvoir amener petit à petit à faire en
sorte que chaque chaque formation est
son référentiel et sa maquette à partir
de là on pourra travailler sur les coups
bon ça c'est juste du travail pour la
directrice générale que je
sur l'apprentissage je crois qu'encore
une fois on est d'accord on est tous
d'accord et et je dirais que aujourd'hui
la main au-delà du au-delà du ministère
elle est c'est vous qui avez la main
c'est vous qui pourrez donner votre
point de vue concernant le futur projet
de loi et si vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec les États du projet de loi j'espère
que vous arriverez à vous faire entendre
en tout cas c'est tout ce qu'on peut
espérer nous notre côté et bon
et puis la remarque de de Monsieur
anneau concernant les concernant le fait
effectivement attention si vous êtes un
travail en couple il va falloir être
compétitif
il y a pas de souci parce que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on est très compétitif on
est déjà compétitif donc je pense qu'on
saura l'être on sera l'être et ça nous
rendra encore plus professionnel donc ça
je faisais pas d'inquiétude là-dessus on
y arrivera voilà bon je vais m'arrêter
là
ce que je veux dire c'est que au total
je pense qu'il y a pas de temps de
désaccord que ça entre nous je crois
qu'on a identifié un petit peu les
quelques points sur lequel on peut
effectivement encore avoir des des
différences d'opinion mais qui sur
lesquelles on peut arriver à des
je pense à un point de vue comme un
moment un autre en tout cas on peut
arriver à réduire peut-être nos
objectifs on n'est pas forcément non
plus dans les mêmes situations donc
c'est peut-être que effectivement pour
ça on peut avoir chacun une opinion un
peu différente mais je crois que le
travail qui est fait en ce moment permet
vraiment d'arriver à
une identification de la situation un
diagnostic et je pense qu'on a jamais
été aussi près d'un dialogue que on est
aujourd'hui merci
une toute petite de précision l'une
concernant le GBT le passage au RCE nous
nous a mis dans une phase transitoire
qui n'est pas achevée aujourd'hui qui
nous est obligé à monter très fortement
en technicité beaucoup de nos emplois il
est quand nous serons en régime établi
on verra les choses différentes et je
pense que les collectivités ont connu ça
aussi sur les droits d'inscription on
l'a évoqué aujourd'hui nous constatons
nous l'avons dit très récemment un
monsieur janisini de
directeur de cabinet adjoint du MESR
pourquoi y a-t-il aujourd'hui par
exemple une différence entre les droits
d'inscription et les écoles d'ingénieurs
publics entre ministères 611 euros ou me
sert 1500 euros au ministère de
l'Agriculture il y a pas de réponse
aujourd'hui à ces questions là
voilà
n'est par le ministère Madame Simone
bonafour je serai en duo avec Frédéric
Forest sur certains sur certains points
alors peut-être partir du
plus haut et je dirais comme Christian
l'hermineau qu'effectivement il y a
d'abord des choix politiques
qui ne relève pas en tout cas même si la
Direction Générale a un avis il relève
du politique au très bon sens du terme
donc c'est vrai que nous sommes en ce
moment en train de lancer donc cette
procédure d'élaboration d'une stratégie
nationale d'enseignement supérieur il
n'y avait pas il y avait une stratégie
de la recherche
qui un moment donné
sera passera sur un soumise à la vie des
parlementaires donc je pense que ça
c'est important c'est important alors
qu'il y a déjà une loi qui vient d'être
votée de se poser des questions de moyen
terme de moyens et long terme enfin
c'est déjà elles sont tellement donc
c'est vrai que la vision que nous avons
en tout cas au ministère de ce travail
sur la stratégie il me semble que c'est
le moment d'ouvrir des questions de
moyens et de long terme dire
qu'effectivement
si on reste le nez sur des sujets qu'on
veut résoudre à moindre à moindre frais
etc dans l'immédiat on n'ira pas très
loin donc nous on pense qu'il y a un
certain nombre de sujets ceux que vous
avez évoqué mais il y en a d'autres
qui doivent être en amont sinon tranché
en tout cas vraiment débattus posé on
peut tout dire sur les droits
d'inscription effectivement il y a des
pays comme la Suède la Finlande qui ont
zéro droit d'inscription les exemples
internationaux on peut les prendre dans
des en tout cas les sujets il faut le
poser parce que c'est pas le sujet de
l'allocation des moyens ces sujets de
l'équilibre économique de l'enseignement
supérieur pour nous il est clair au
ministère que ce sujet est posé enfin
nous on le vit tous les jours il y a un
sujet là comme on dit dans les
ministères vraiment bon donc un moment
donné je pense qu'on peut pas passer à
côté après les réponses on des réponses
politiques les
drones d'épices mais nous nous donnerons
pas la réponse parce que la réponse je
crois que ça a été dit sous d'autres
mais la réponse est profondément
politique donc oui bien sûr pour que ce
débat soit ouvert et je pense que la
ministre
considère aussi que c'est le rôle de de
la future stratégie de débattre de ces
sujets que ce soit débattus au Parlement
ça c'est le premier point et
effectivement on découle ensuite un
certain nombre de d'éléments mais il y
aura pas que ça évidemment dans la
stratégie je crois que la question telle
qu'elle a été posée de ce
que l'on veut comme
ce qu'on veut faire en termes de
formation les ambitions qu'on se donne
en termes de formation les ambitions
qu'on termine de recherche et comment on
dose l'effort de la Nation par rapport à
ça bon je pense ça fait partie
effectivement des des sujets j'aurais
simplement dire ensuite passer sur des
quelques autres sujets que pour
l'instant ma connaissance il n'y a
jamais eu de pénalisation si je puis
dire ou de prise en compte négatif des
ressources propres d'un établissement
dans la location des moyens par l'État
l'État n'a jamais calculé un besoin
global d'un établissement dont il aurait
d'abord commencé par défalquer les
ressources propres ça à ma connaissance
ça ne s'est jamais fait j'aurais quand
même rassurer sur ce sur ce point alors
ensuite la question qui est posée
effectivement que vous avez posé
monsieur sénateur en particulier c'est
la répartition des emplois entre des
1000 emplois par an entre la politique
de site et puis la convergence donc le
choix qui a été fait par la par la
ministre et nous-mêmes et présenté aux
conférences ça a été de répartir ces
5000 emplois à 65 35 65 sur la
convergence 35 soit politique de site
mais ce que je voudrais dire c'est un
choix politique là aussi qui est mais
c'est pas pour financer comment dire
c'est pas pour financer je sais pas le
fonctionnement des de superstructures
qui existent très souvent d'ailleurs
déjà sous la forme de presse ou bon les
établissements et certains nombre
d'entre eux sont déjà reg si on déjà
donc c'est pas la question en fait ça
accompagne la politique contractuelle
donc ce que je voudrais dire c'est que
il y a toujours eu de la part enfin puis
qui existent des contrats en tout cas
donc depuis une quinzaine d'années il y
a un soutien de l'État au moment de la
négociation contractuelle donc de fait
la politique dite de site est en même
temps à la politique contractuelle
j'insiste parce que c'est ça le vrai
sens en réalité donc dans le contrat
précédent le contrat était en fait en
des moyens de financement c'était des
euros il n'y avait aucun emploi depuis
pas mal d'années bon là on a la station
inverse
cela dit il faut savoir quand même que
le bonus du précédent contrat a été mis
en base des établissements bon on est
passé discrètement enfin
jamais rappelé mais je le signale parce
que c'est quand même
en plus de ce que donne le modèle c'est
et ça abonde d'ailleurs les excédents
pour certains ou au contraire ça comble
les déficit pour d'autres mais
ça peut aller de 1 million à 3 millions
enfin je pense tout le très gros
établissement qui était du bonus
contractuel et qui de fait nous avons
mis en base dans le financement des
établissements je tiens quand même à le
dire donc une fois ce bonus contractuel
de fait engrangé en quelque sorte et bon
il y a pas de nous n'avons pas l'état
d'âme là-dessus mais je crois que ça a
abondé les établissements de fête
maintenant
cette dans cette période c'est vrai que
c'est l'inverse si je puis dire il n'y a
plus de lignes budgétaires votées au PLF
pour la négociation contractuelle et
donc c'est une partie des emplois des
1000 emplois qui abondent cette
politique et comme il se trouve que dans
la loi vous le savez les contrats sont
pensés au niveau du site
avec un regroupement d'établissement au
niveau du site c'est ça en fait qui est
abondé c'est pas du fonctionnement c'est
de la politique c'est à dire que ce
qu'on demande aux établissements
regroupés c'est quelles sont les
politiques sur lesquelles ils souhaitent
que nous mettions des emplois et ces
emplois peuvent très bien être mis au
niveau de chacun des établissements si
par exemple la fonction internationale
est portée par l'un pour les quatre ou
si la fonction entrepreneuriale est
portée nous on n'a pas de religion du
lieu on doit mettre les emplois ce qu'on
abonde c'est une politique regroupée
donc c'est en fait toujours de la
politique contractuelle mais monter au
niveau du site donc vraiment je
je souhaite que ce soit assez clair
alors de ce fait c'est vrai que les 1000
emplois les multiples par 5000 bon pour
cette raison mais certainement pour
d'autres aussi je vais venir sur la la
sensibilité du modèle qui est d'ailleurs
qu'on a éprouvé cette année puisqu'on a
légèrement changé le la façon d'utiliser
le modèle pour la location des emplois
convergence totale je ne pense pas cela
dit on ne parle que des emplois là il y
a bien d'autres facteurs d'inégalité
entre les établissements et vous en avez
mentionné un qui est par exemple les
mètres carrés
vous avez des établissements qui ont 300
000 m² à rendre qui voudrait bien y
arriver d'ailleurs bon et puis vous en
avez d'autres je pense le cas évidemment
c'est pareil
le summum de l'absence de maître carré
bon alors du coup dans le modèle parce
qu'on ne compte pas parce que le modèle
n'est pas
le modèle n'est pas tributaire du nombre
de mètres carrés dans le cas présent je
pense à Paris parce que c'est exemplaire
effectivement ça fait qu'il a
heureusement encore une certaine façon
une sorte de compensation les moyens
qu'il a qui ne sont pas tributeurs de
mètres carrés ça lui compense un peu
cette pauvreté en mètre carré mais
j'insiste quand même là-dessus et puis
il y a beaucoup d'autres inégalités il y
a la région dans laquelle on est il y a
là enfin bon même chose d'être en région
parisienne et d'être à Pau enfin bon il
y a beaucoup beaucoup d'autres
inégalités que uniquement celles sur les
emplois cela dit sur les emplois parce
que c'est celle là que vous posez et on
peut être sur encadré en emploi et une
palette en moyen
peut être les deux enfin bon il y a
quand même différents cas de figure
dire que ce qu'on voit au bout de deux
de deux années où on utilise le modèle
et c'est vrai comme modèle d'aide à la
décision pour attribuer les emplois ça
tout à fait a été bien dit mais on l'a
utilisé à d'autres occasions comme un
modèle d'aide à la décision sur les
répartitions c'est vrai que
les extrêmes ne bougent pas enfin
massivement c'est-à-dire qu'on se
retrouve pas avec un établissement qui
avait 35 emplois à l'an dernier qui
était considérés dans le summum du
manque d'emploi et qui se retrouverait
cette année
parce que les positions un peu bougé à
l'autre à l'autre extrême mais par
contre par exemple cette année ça montre
l'intérêt quand même de travailler sur
le modèle d'allocation des moyens cette
année nous avons pour attribuer les
emplois tenus compte du modèle en tant
que tel et puis nous avons pour 30% des
emplois que nous attribuons à la
convergence tenue compte de ce qu'on a
appelé la pression à la licence
d'ailleurs à la demande de nous enfin
c'est une suggestion de la de la cure
avec laquelle je pense nous devons bien
travailler sur cette question c'est à
dire le pourcentage d'étudiants de
licence sur l'ensemble des étudiants
d'un établissement bon donc il y a eu
dans l'attribution dans la façon
d'utiliser le modèle d'allocation des
moyens il y a une prime au poids de la
licence sur l'ensemble mais c'est un
sacrément s'en servir
je trouve que je voyais président Nîmes
ce matin effectivement ça change la
donne pour un certain nombre
d'établissements ça change la donne bon
et quand c'est anime Nîmes par exemple
qui passe effectivement de 9 à 18
mémoire 9 à 18 emplois entre les deux
années bon mais c'est aussi bien entendu
que celui-ci qui a beaucoup d'étudiants
de licence et aussi celui qui a 60% de
boursiers enfin bon voilà donc de fait
on a quand même
ça voilà la convergence est en route
elle ne sera pas totale et elle est
extrêmement sensible vous voyez le
simple fait qu'on est mis plus l'accent
là donc vraiment je pense qu'il faut
bien mesurer que que c'est ces questions
c'est pour ça qu'on essaye nous de dire
les de parler d'écart de dotation plutôt
que de sûr ou de sous dotation parce que
sur ou sous par rapport à quoi au niveau
européen au niveau international bon qui
donne l'impression que les uns ou les
autres oui enfin bon donc je pense qu'il
faut vrai c'est un écart de dotation
dans un ensemble qui est fermé et bon
voilà donc on est sur du relatif
ce que je voudrais dire aussi c'est
en ce qui concerne le calcul des coûts
et la pondération oui heureusement c'est
déjà pondéré le modèle est déjà pondéré
en fonction je vous rassure on est
personne le modèle qui mérite dans le
modèle précédent
mais maintenant il y a des gens très
compétents on pourrait faire mais je
donne mon avis mais personne n'a quand
même imaginé que dans le modèle on a les
financer de la même façon une formation
d'ingénieur et une formation de droit
pour autant et ça a été dit par évidente
de Limoges université de Limoges bien
entendu quand on travaille
quand on observe les coûts et quand on
fait un travail sur les coups il faut
pas se contenter donc l'observation
c'est toujours utile après il s'agit pas
coller forcément à l'observation donc je
crois que aujourd'hui on a encore des
marges de progrès sur l'observation donc
il y a tout un chantier calcul des coûts
qui est mené et je pense quand même que
connaître le réel est une bonne chose
donc qui est menée par par la dg6 avec
l'appui NR avec l'appui des consultant
interne du ministère enfin on y a mis
des moyens
on commence à avoir des réels des réels
données mais c'est pas qu'un problème de
discipline parce que certes il y a le
problème de discipline et il s'agit pas
de coller au réel il faudra savoir quand
et c'est politique quand est-ce qu'on
veut décoller du réel parce qu'on pense
qu'il faut améliorer justement et ça
peut être des fois assez fin tu l'as
très bien dit au sein de l'ensemble
d'ingénierie bon voilà tout n'est pas
équivalent et on sait très bien que les
maths dans le secteur des sciences et la
technologie c'est pareil ça entre les
maths et la physique bon c'est dans le
même ensemble et honnêtement c'est pas
du même ordre bon en termes de coût donc
il y a c'est il y a aller assez fin dans
cet état d'un nombre de cas mais il y a
aussi d'autres questions c'est la part
et c'est fondamental la part
effectivement le coût recherche était
une vraiment une question
et nous sommes complètement d'accord
avec la CP et la cdfi sur le fait qu'il
faut vraiment que le coût de la
recherche soit évalué après après on
décide comment on fait bouger les lignes
mais c'est pas possible de sous-évaluer
à ce point le coût de la recherche en
particulier en termes d'immobilier de
logistique de fluides etc donc ça c'est
ça c'est très important donc la part
recherche la performation les coûts des
uns par rapport aux autres puis les
coûts du dés elle et M la ministre
répète ceci très souvent mais je pense
qu'elle a raison il faut effectivement
qu'on regarde au-delà des disciplines ce
que chaque établissement met sur les
différents niveaux parce qu'un plan
licence c'est un plus les plans licence
précédents ou les emplois que nous
mettons c'est des plus mais quand même
c'est non pas 12 mais 14 milliards bon
de que nous mettons sur l'enseignement
supérieur donc ce que nous dont nous
parlons là les emplois en plus chaque
année c'est sur cinq ans c'est 500
millions
bon donc certes c'est du c'est du plus
mais c'est pas ça qui transforme le
enfin les établissements font leur
politique avec tous leurs moyens pas
simplement avec le plus du plan licence
à un moment donné ou avec le plus des
emplois que nous avons aujourd'hui donc
c'est très important que cette question
de l'équilibre recherche formation elle
elle MD soit vraiment creusé comparer
avec d'autres pays puis après il y a des
décisions politiques moi je continue à
dire à un moment donné il y a des
décisions politiques qui sont qui sont à
prendre bon voilà essentiellement ce que
je voulais dire je pense que tu peux
peut-être préciser sur les boursiers la
façon dont on travaille sur les sur les
boursiers et puis peut-être d'autres
points que tu as noté
peut-être pour compléter rapidement donc
les propos de la directrice générale sur
les boursiers afin qu'il n'y ait pas
d'ambiguïté sur la question cette année
c'est à dire pour 2014 le gouvernement a
engagé une réforme de ce film enfin sur
sur ce thème et donc la compensation
boursière donc les 95 millions d'euros
qui correspondent à l'exonération qui
sont en grande partie dans le modèle ont
été sortis donc en 2014 la question la
question le sujet lié à la compensation
de l'exonération des droits des
étudiants boursiers il est traité hors
modèle donc on a identifié une
autorisation hors modèle et l'idée est
de faire converger cette dotation en 4
ans vers la l'exonération réelle qui
correspond réellement aux
droits que devrait percevoir
l'établissement pour dans 4 ans faire
varier cette dotation directement en
fonction du nombre d'étudiants boursiers
donc clairement c'est une aujourd'hui la
une dotation et fléchée elle va évoluer
sur quatre ans pour arriver exactement
au montant à compenser et après elle va
vivre sa vie en fonction du nombre
d'étudiants boursiers donc vraiment là
le chemin est clairement engagé vers une
compensation réelle pour que ce soit
clair par ailleurs on a une notification
qui par d'ici la fin de la semaine aux
établissements qui expliquent ces
mécanismes là même s'ils ont été
discutés viennent bien évidemment en
amont
peut-être
simplement donner une indication sur ce
qui a pu être dit sur les produits dans
les étudiants en licence et autres le
ministère et notamment dans son son
département d'allocation des moyens à
conduit des travaux précis pour
identifier ce qu'on pouvait appeler des
effets propres termes à ces techniques
pour identifier quoi pour
identifier quel est l'impact par exemple
de 100 de 100 étudiants de santé
étudiants de plus en licence de science
aujourd'hui on l'estime à 76000 euros
donc en gros un établissement qui aurait
100 étudiant de plus en licence il
aurait 76000 euros de plus dans le dans
le modèle et bien ça correspond
aujourd'hui en gros à trois produisant
en plus qui seraient dans un laboratoire
noté a donc on a fait ce travail là
qu'on a communiqué aux conférences lors
d'un comité de pilotage et qu'on a aussi
présenté au Conseil National de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche pour arriver à mettre sur la
table les effets du modèle et qui soient
bien connus évidemment c'est un travail
qu'on va faire en détail pour le
prochain
il faut absolument qu'on puisse
connaître à l'avance quels sont les
effets de ce donc ça c'est c'est
vraiment quelque chose qu'on a mené
évidemment pour que les choses soient
très claires et on a les documents qui
ont été distribués on voit on a ces
chiffres très clairement et très
précisément et je salue le travail qui a
été mené sur sur cette question et
peut-être pour ne pas rallonger
notre réponse simplement dire sur les
sur les efforts ou les encouragements
bon évidemment il y a jamais eu de
on n'a jamais défavorisé un
établissement qui aurait plus de plus de
ressources propres jamais ça c'est
vraiment voir à l'international parfois
s'il y a une augmentation de dotation
quand il y a des ressources propres
n'est jamais de baisse
simplement je veux dire sur
l'encouragement de de l'effort le modèle
sympa il a servi ces cinq dernières
années en quelque sorte il a clairement
servi effectivement et la série
notamment rattrapage pour moduler
l'augmentation de de moyens et ça a été
moduler on l'a rappelé aussi dans les
réponses à vos questionnaires ou au
Conseil national de manière parfois
assez puisqu'on va de 5% à 50%. qui a
diversité qui sur la période ont vu
leurs moyens sur le fonctionnement sur
les 2 milliards de fonctionnement ont vu
leurs moyens augmenter de 5%, d'autres
de 50 donc on a clairement il y a eu une
modulation y compris par exemple en 2012
où il y a eu un rattrapage de 15
millions d'euros moduler dont 8
effectivement spécifiquement sur les
sous dotés donc certes il y a pas eu de
redéploiement ou de rééquilibrage direct
ou de transfert de notation il y a
clairement eu l'utilisation de ce modèle
pour pour arriver à rendre à avoir une
allocation plus équitable
merci de ces précisions j'ai demandé à
mon chef de service ce que vous
entendiez par équivalent de sang
étudiants en licence avec le cou et puis
trois en production et je vous voulais
savoir si vous parliez financent quoi
coup et effectivement vous parliez
finance mais ce qui nous intéresse ce
qui nous intéresse nous ça sera aussi
puisque vous renvoyez la décision
politique au choix et je pense qu'il est
pas maniché c'est pas ou ou c'est comme
la biodiversité un plus il y en a plus
lieu d'orchidées mais justement ce qui
serait intéressant c'est justement sur
ces efforts financiers sur le plan
licence combien ça fait émerger de
chercheurs etc quoi la rentabilité
intellectuelle et productive en quelque
sorte de ce plan licence ça aussi ça
nous intéresse je pense que nous pouvons
arrêtez nos travaux je profite de votre
présence pour vous donner une
information qui vous concerne la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et de la Communication
a choisi cette année comme thème pour sa
mission d'information
l'installation des espèces alors nous
avons que vous avez dû dans la
précipitation faire remonter des
maquettes avant même que la navette de
la loi n'est finissons parcours ce qui
était quand même un exercice
particulièrement difficile et scabreux
mais justement nous voudrions
accompagner cette installation cette
première année de défrichage parce que
le législateur a inscrit des choses un
peu innovantes à savoir que les
enseignants les enseignements de nos
futurs enseignants seront faits par des
universitaires à titre disciplinaire des
universitaires sur les de l'éducation
mais aussi par des acteurs de
l'éducation populaire et les artistes et
ces gens là n'ont pas encore trouvé la
porte des universités pour dire on est
là on peut intervenir etc et je pense
que les dialogues avec les personnes
parlementaires de cette mission seront
utiles pour voir vos possibilités vos
difficultés pour mettre en place ce que
les législateurs à vous de je vous
remercie
voilà pour les travaux de la commission
de la culture du Sénat sur la réforme du
financement des universités tout de
suite la suite des programmes sur Public
Sénat et on se retrouve à partir du 19h
pour 24 heures Sénat le journal à tout à
l'heure